we're going to get started ladies and
gentlemen
let me say good morning to all of you
i'd like to preface my remarks by
thanking chairman wirth for scheduling
these very important hearings
and for his leadership with regard to
the issues of enhancing diversity in the
media
and increasing minority participation in
the broadcast industries
i know chairman wirth would very much
like to be himself to greet you
unfortunately because of a scheduling
conflict that he was unable to avoid he
will not be able to be here as we begin
this hearing he will however be here
shortly
i welcome this opportunity to
participate in this discussion on the
problems confronted by minorities in the
media particularly with regard to the
persistence of stereotypical portrayals
of minorities
i think it is particularly appropriate
for the subcommittee to consider the
broadcast industry's treatment of
minorities and minority concerns now
as we begin to actively consider
legislation geared toward deregulating
broadcasting
i must confess
that i often wonder given the shabby
treatment of minorities in a regulated
environment
how will we fare after deregulation
moreover
i wonder if we truly can build into any
deregulation legislation sufficient
structural safeguards to ensure that the
needs and concerns of all of our
citizens black brown and white
old and young rich or poor
urban or rural
are served by the broadcasting industry
it is clear to any observer of the
television industry that the record of
the industry with regard to portrayal of
minorities
and
enunciation of minority concerns is and
historically has been abysmal
there has been very little educational
or informational programming geared
toward minority audiences on either
local or network television
there has been even less effort
to accurately portray minority life in
standard commercial entertainment fair
far too often talented minority actors
and actresses are reduced to
stereotypical portrayals or comedic
roles
a report concerning the television
industry prepared by the united states
commission on civil rights noted that
when blacks appear on television they
rarely are portrayed seriously
the report also noted that while whites
are often shown in ridiculous roles in
television they also are seen in other
programs and roles while minorities
appear most often in situation comedies
according to the report the roles of
blacks in television situation comedies
largely fixes an image in the public
mind of a ridiculous and non-serious
person
in the absence of any balance these
shows grossly distort minority life in
america
serve to reinforce negative images of
minority life and boast the societal
racism and sexism
i'm concerned with the impact television
programming has
on the minds of our populace at large
but i'm particularly concerned about the
effect this programming has on the young
both minority and
non-minority the richness and vitality
of the minority experience in america is
rarely if ever depicted on television
because of this omission the american
public is denied the opportunity to view
realistically
and socially meaningful programming and
young p young children of all races are
denied minority role models
what is particularly disheartening is
that there does not appear
to be any effort on the part of those
people most responsible for programming
decisions to do anything to remedy the
situation
this this month the three major networks
are unveiling their fall programs
after reviewing the new schedule it is
evident
that as far as minorities are concerned
it is business as usual in hollywood
most of the new programming particularly
dramatic series are devoid of minority
cast members in either leading or
supporting roles
those few new shows that do feature
minorities in prominent roles are more
situation comedies
the same as has been almost forever
one of these shows features and i quote
shaboo
a hip genie only with soul
this is just what television needs in
1983. a black sex a black slave happily
doing the bidding of his white master
and this really is this really the best
the industry has to offer
much less it's minority viewers
i'm also concerned about the absence of
minority family life on television
other than alex haley's palmerstown
series a few years ago
there have been no weekly dramatic
series involving black family life
television is devoid of black nuclear
families instead the powers that be
in television
would rather do treatments of cute and
sassy black orphans taken in by
benevolent white households is it not
ironic that in a medium
that that has no regularly scheduled
series featuring black family life
there are now two series featuring black
children adopted by white households
did arnold of different strokes really
need a clone
more importantly did television or the
viewing audience
really need a clone of arnold
my tv guide also brought me some other
welcome news about this false season's
schedule
beginning last saturday we have a new
addition to the saturday morning
children's television ghetto
yes despite popular demand mr t now has
a saturday morning tv series in addition
to his heartwarming role on the a team
while i'm certain that mr t is a
genuinely nice and well-meaning
individual i'm concerned whether the
character he portrays is the best
possible role model for children
i'm also
dismayed that he is quite possibly the
most visible black person on television
i question why an industry which has
studiously avoided portraying the
pantheon of black heroes which spans
this country's history chooses to make a
black folk hero for our children out of
mr t
in the 50s and 60s america's folk heroes
were daniel boone
david crockett and the cartwrights of
bonanza
there were no black heroes in the 70s we
had kojak beretta and starskin hutch
not to mention charlie charlie's angels
again no black or hispanic or other
minority heroes
now in the 80s we have mr t
i guess hollywood
could call that progress
in our discussion today
i hope
i sincerely very seriously hope we will
have an opportunity to discuss some of
the solutions to the problems we are all
concerned with
what can and should be
done in congress
and what can our counterparts in the
industry do to remedy the situation in
hollywood that perpetuates tokenism and
stereotyping
this is not a new problem since the
advent of the television industry
minorities have fought for fair
treatment at the hands of television's
writers producers and network executives
but in 40 years of television there has
been market
markedly little progress
unless one considers it
progress to go from a maid and beulah to
a maid and give me a break
or seize the trip from amos and andy to
mr t as progress or takes comfort in the
history that begins with farina and
buckwheat
and concludes for the moment with arnold
and webster
is it progress to have begun with a
character like steppen fetchit and have
it evolved no farther than shabu the
jive genie
i don't consider it progress
it is still a distorted view of minority
life by white writers for white viewers
i hope that one day television and the
other communications media will be as
good as they are capable of being
i hope that minorities will not have to
continue to avert their eyes and shame
about the portrayals of our lives
but instead can view with prior
programming
documenting our con
contributions to this nation
it is my sincere hope that from this
hearing
we will all gain a better understanding
and appreciation of how the industry
responds to the needs and interests of
the minority community
i also hope
that this hearing will serve to
crystallize the concerns of the minority
community with regard to broadcast
deregulation
and concluding my remarks i would like
to
acknowledge the efforts by
those distinguished assemblies of
panelists
i know that many of you travel great
distances
and postponed or cancelled various
professional and personal commitments in
order to attend this hearing i would
like to extend my personal thanks for
that
and the appreciation of my colleagues on
this subcommittee
i now would like to yield to my
colleague from texas
the honorable john bryant
for our opening statement thank you mr
chairman
i wish to associate myself with your
remarks and to come commend
the chairman worth as well as
congressman leland for calling this
hearing today on minorities in the media
to explore the impact of broadcast
deregulation
on efforts to improve minority
representation in television programming
as well as media ownership and equal
employment opportunity
the substantial under-representation of
minorities in media ownership and
programming is a significant personal
concern of mine and of many other
members of congress and i think he would
do do
the broadcast industry
well to
be on notice that it is not only the
black members of congress that are
concerned about this but their white
colleagues
many of them in the house and senate as
well there is a broad
i think consensus among the members of
congress that this is a serious problem
and it is one that i hope that we were
able to address in this congressional
session
even the bare bones data that we on this
subcommittee have received show how
underrepresented blacks hispanics and
other minority groups are
in television entertainment programming
now i mentioned entertainment
programming the situation is even worse
and more dismal with regard to
non-entertainment programming
programs which portray minority
individuals in only comedic or service
worker roles do a disservice
not only to minority people but to
all americans
and continued reinforcement of negative
stereotypes
do not further efforts toward successful
integration of our business communities
of our national economy as a whole our
neighborhoods or any other part of
american life
programs which portray black people
hispanic people and other groups
as cooks and janitors instead of
teachers and civil servants or as
doctors and lawyers
and not only believe the success
successes that members of minority
groups have achieved but
misstate
our national aspirations for members of
these minority groups
today i am pleased to become a
co-sponsor of house resolution
1155 sponsored by mrs cartis collins
this minority telecommunications
development act of 1983 would improve
minority ownership of broadcast stations
and ensure equal
employment opportunities
broadcast deregulation legislation which
will be considered by this subcommittee
in the near future must contain the
basic provisions of h.r 1155
i am confident that the subcommittee
and the full energy and commerce
committee will pass legislation
which preserves the small gains that
have been made by minorities in the
broadcast media
and guarantees that progress will
continue to be made until minority
groups are adequately and fairly
represented in the media
i also believe that strong language
guaranteeing equal employment
opportunities will be part of any
legislative package
i'm also proud to be a co-sponsor
of the minority telecommunications
ownership tax act which was authored by
congressman leland as another means of
assisting minorities in acquiring
broadcast stations by offering tax
incentives to enable
minority groups to attract necessary
capital to buy broadcast stations
i look forward this morning to hearing
of the experiences of our distinguished
witnesses
most especially i wish to hear their
opinions and suggestions for improvement
in light of the legislative proposals
under consideration to eliminate
comparative renewal and fcc licensing
procedures
i share missed congressman leland's
concern about the direction we may be
going with regard to broadcast
deregulation
and the possible impact that it may have
in the future on minority programming
particularly in view of the fact that
even under a heavily regulated
scheme
there's been relatively little progress
and i want to restate one more time
perhaps in light of what happened over
the weekend
[Music]
no no one was happier than i was or that
i think many white americans shared the
the interest in seeing the racial
barrier broken at the miss america
pageant i think it was saturday night
when a black american was chosen as miss
america
but i hope that will not be
seized upon by people who want to go
slow in the area that congressman leland
is trying to lead us into
those people might be inclined to say
well this show is a great deal of
progress i would think it would be
important to
recognize that
miss america is an entertainment figure
and blacks are well represented in the
well represented in the entertainment
segment of of the media i think we're
here today to talk about what we can do
to
see black families black professionals
and
normal black
day-to-day life portrayed accurately in
the media and i congratulate congressman
leland for bringing us here today
thank you
congressman bates from california
thank you mr chairman my uh sincere
thanks to congressman mickey leland for
the leadership he's demonstrated today
in calling these hearings
unfortunately racial discrimination is a
fact of life in america in 1983.
any deregulation or lessening of
regulations or the broadcast industry
should be tied to specific tradeoffs or
proposals which improve
the problems that will be identified at
the hearings here today
i think the title minorities in the
media the impact of broadcast
deregulation and
portrayal of minorities and other issues
the linking of those subjects is most
appropriate
from congressional staff subcommittees
and committee staffs to federal
commissions and the broadcast industry
affording minorities equal opportunity
and hiring practices
is
still not adequate in the need of
dramatic improvement
while the overall quality of television
programming is poor filled with racial
and other violence and a lack of
adequate children's programming the
roles of minorities
is most inadequate of all
so i'm here today to listen and learn
and pledge my total support to your
leadership mr living thank you
thank you
the gentleman from california mr waxman
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to join my colleagues in commending you
for holding this hearing i think it's
important for us to get an airing of
this issue and to see what legislative
proposals we might adopt
our responsibility in the congress as it
relates to the
to the television media
is to make sure that we give the
american people an opportunity for
diversity of programming
and to
have the opportunity for this very
important media to bring about new ideas
and and communications about the lives
of people in a way that will actually
communicate reality
unfortunately as you have pointed out we
see
stereotyping perpetuated by
by the television media so often that
it has to distress any of us as we look
at the potential that's lost from this
very important communications vehicle i
think our objective has to be
for full participation of all of our
people both in front of the cameras and
behind the cameras we want the
stereotyping to be eliminated and we
also want full opportunity in all
employment in the industry to be
afforded all people so i want to commend
you and to
to pledge my support to work with you on
any legislation that would be helpful in
this regard
thank you so much we'll now proceed to
our panel
we have with us today
we're still waiting uh hopefully they
will arrive during the course of the
first panel
uh
let's see that's six i think witnesses
schedule but we have present now
uh mrs wilhelmina ruben cook who is with
the citizens communications center
we have uh
mr raul
isigera
who is with the national council of la
raza
we have uh substituting for uh mr ben
hooks who is unable to be here with us
who is president of the naacp mr uh
willa davis who is the
oh i'm sorry willis edwards who is
forgive me willis
even a very very good friend willis
edwards who is president of the naacp
chapter of beverly hills and
i'm sorry hollywood uh
who is uh
is very very well known in this area who
has been i guess leading the fight for
the naacp to try to to get some changes
made with
minorities in the media
and
peggy sharon
i'm sorry peggy
she's with action 4 children's
television and we very much welcome you
because we know what the problems are
with stereotyping of children
in in television represents and you have
been very much involved for so long so
we'll now proceed and i'll now recognize
mrs uh wilhelmina ruben cook
and members of the subcommittee i
appreciate the opportunity to appear
before you this morning on behalf of
citizens communications center and black
citizens for fair media to discuss our
mutual concerns and dissatisfaction with
the present level of participation in
the presence of minorities in the
telecommunications industry
citizens is a washington dc public
interest law firm which
assists citizens groups and community
groups such as black citizens for fair
media on communications issues
from whatever perspective we adopt be it
numbers or betrayal we must conclude
that we fall woefully short of the
objectives of full economic and artistic
participation in the media
even more troubling are the indicia that
the images of minorities presented by
the media are at best infrequent and at
worst
stereotypic and negative indeed one
looking at television would assume that
america has very few minorities and all
of them are black i will not
review uh sections of winter dressing on
the set the historic civil rights
commission report except to emphasize
their finding that from 69 to 74
the commission concluded that minorities
were disproportionately underrepresented
in numbers economic status and portrayal
in serious versus comic roles
responding to criticisms of outdated
statistics the commission published an
update in 79 the conclusion the
portrayal of minorities had not improved
since 1974 indeed in some cases
stereotyping had actually increased
i doubt that anyone who testifies today
will seriously suggest the situation has
improved since the end of the seventies
indeed the likelihood is that you will
be presented with more graphic and
anecdotal evidence that the situation
has worsened
there are essentially two ways of
improving the portrayal and increasing
the presence and participation of
minorities in the electronic media
minority ownership and regulation i fear
that both approaches are under serious
contemporary challenge
less than two percent of the nation's
broadcast facilities are minority owned
despite the fact that minorities
comprise more than 20 percent of the
nation's population
significantly increased minority
ownership is key in addressing the
inadequate presence and distorted
representation of minorities throughout
all levels of the media
it is a licensee after all who is
ultimately responsible for identifying
the needs interest and problems of the
community and determining what if any
responsive programming is to be
broadcast the opinion shaping influence
of the licensee on a community through
the selection of news items public
affairs issues political and general
editorials can be graphically attested
to by its beneficiaries and victims
alike the licensee is also ultimately
responsible for employment practices at
the station
unfortunately present ownership
statistics and a realistic assessment of
current deregulatory initiatives do not
suggest significant future improvements
with respect to minority ownership
first even with a doubling of the
statistics since the exception of the
commission's minority policy statement
we are just at the two percent ownership
mark secondly this increase was based
primarily on the distressed sales policy
which permits a licensee who has been
designated for hearing to transfer a
station to a minority at 75 percent of
the fair market value and thereby avoid
hearing of the possible loss of a
financial interest in the license i
think it is important to know that the
distressed sales policy which has been
key in doubling minority ownership was
in fact tied to the regulatory structure
and that most of these resulted from
serious petitions to deny based on
regulations many of which have been are
in the process of being dismantled so
what we have seen as a doubling we
cannot anticipate in the future simply
because in the area of radio we've had
deregulation now this this is not to
argue for a labyrinth of arcane
inefficient rules on the theory that the
more rules we have the more likely we
are to catch some licensee thereby
increasing the chances for distress
sales it does suggest however that we
look carefully at the various proposals
for particular deregulatory initiatives
and their interaction with other policy
objectives this is particularly true in
the area of structural regulation i'd
like to examine for a moment multiple
ownership restrictions
removal of ownership restrictions and
this is putting aside questions of the
new unique dangers of concentration in
the in the communications industry
removal of ownership restrictions
including cross ownership and regional
concentration rules will undermine
opportunities for minority ownership by
forcing emerging minority entrepreneurs
to compete with larger increasingly
vertically integrated highly capitalized
and more established telecommunications
firms removal of ownership restrictions
also vitiates the incentive for those
firms to invest in minority firms
thereby further undermine mining various
minority ownership initiatives vigilance
with respect to equal opportunity is
also important in ensuring full
participation of minorities in the media
there have been serious attempts by the
fcc to decrease
to raise reporting thresholds and we
know that that at the smaller stations
where turnover is high and entry level
positions are available that it is here
that minorities and women are most
likely to get a foothold on the
employment ladder i'll just run through
and summarize some of the other points i
think that any deregulatory legislation
must be tied to strong ownership
restrictions and eeo regulations if it
is to be meaningful the other question
is in terms of of quantification as
opposed to
the regulatory scheme in my testimony i
give examples of ways in which various
groups have used the petition to deny
process and the public interest standard
in order to have leverage with local
broadcast licensees and to obtain at the
local level more responsive programming
it is clear that this has not been the
answer to everything but i think the
subcommittee in thinking about any kind
of deregulatory uh initiative has to
ensure that there is tied to that kind
of legislation some leverage so that
citizens groups and minority groups at
the local level can confront
broadcasters with their problems and
broadcasters have an incentive to be
responsible and responsive to them
finally i'd like to address the question
how the subcommittee's present efforts
to develop consensus legislation
deregulating the broadcast industry and
quantifying the public interest standard
can also address the need for minority
participation and ownership of the media
i'd like to make three points i think
first the subcommittee must recognize
that the needs of the minority audience
are congruent with the primary need of
all listeners and viewers we need and we
deserve as owners of the airwaves the
best practical service this means that
any standards and i'm assuming standards
not agreeing with quantification at all
but addressing the the question is posed
to me
that any standard that has
has to be set high enough to achieve the
goals of the comparative renewal system
i question whether or not this is
possible particularly in light of the
industry's refusal to provide statistics
to the subcommittee so they can make a
reasoned and reasonable assessment of
what the public interest standard should
be i think one of the difficulties that
the industry looking at their radio
compounds have learned yes virginia one
can get something for nothing
secondly i think the citizens is
proposed in a number of of instances a
kind of program calculus in which
several program categories could be
established with percentages for minimal
substantial superior service it would be
necessary to ensure that one of the
categories that is mandatory would be
minority programming otherwise i think
we would see what we have today that
minority programming would drop out of
the picture in terms of quantification
so if it's a serious attempt it must be
one of the
the prerequisite kind of categories
additionally quantification could also
recognize non-programming criteria such
as eeo profile given the presumed
relationship between minority employment
and programming responsiveness the fact
that a licensee's eeo profile in the top
four job categories had reached parity
not zone of reasonable disparity could
be counted as a credit toward the
renewal expectancy similarly failure to
meet existing eeo standards would result
in a substantial demerit or
disqualification thank you
thank you
i will have
it's we we've have had to join us by the
way uh dr j fred mcdonald from
northeastern illinois raul is he guerra
now
and the chair would like to recognize
you
thank you very much congressman
i would like to um
ask permission that my testimony be
inserted in the record
the chair encourages uh all of his
panelists if they will to summarize
their statements and submit
their full testimony for the record if
you will
thank you and i will just
direct my attention to major portions of
my testimony
let me first
state that the your opening remarks uh
mr chairman
were very eloquent and gave us a very
good portrayal of the situation in the
black community but the situation in the
hispanic community which i try to
portray in my testimony is
more egregious and that deserves our our
collective attention
i come before this committee wearing uh
three separate hats i'm the uh president
of the national council of la raza one
of the major hispanic organizations in
the country
i am also the chairman and chief
executive officer of la raza production
center a
a for-profit organization dedicated to
try to
provide
programming material to a public and
commercial television
and also as chairman of the board of
associated southwest investors a mesbic
which concentrates and focuses much of
its attention on financing of
minority radio and television
properties
let me give you a little bit of an
overview of the hispanic involvement in
the electronic media
it's characterized by extreme
underrepresentation and station
ownership and control
policy making at the network
headquarters and local station level
within the fcc
overall employment and on-air portrayals
when hispanics do appear on the air
presentations are very frequently
inaccurate negative and insulting
stereotypes let me summarize the current
conditions regarding portrayals and
stereotyping in the relationship to
ownership and employment
portrayal of hispanics
it has become widely accepted that the
electronic media and especially
television are quote major socializing
force
in the united states
consciously and unconsciously viewers
tend to adopt many of the perspectives
presented on the screen and to see the
nation as it is portrayed not only on
the evening news but also in situation
comedies detective shows and other
fictional programming
it is also widely recognized at least by
specialists in the field that the
current portrayals of minorities on
television tend to reinforce ethnic and
racial stereotypes
hispanics have been severely victimized
by such portrayals
far too little has changed in nine years
since the publication of window dressing
on the set and its update by the united
states commission on civil rights
hispanics rarely appear
on prime time television and when they
do they are usually cast as low low
status persons figures of fun or
juvenile delinquents both television and
radio news presentations generally
ignore hispanic issues newscasters
mispronounce hispanic names and few
hispanics serve as news correspondents
or quote experts
minority oriented public affairs
broadcasting remains limited and is
rarely aired during prime time or fringe
prime time periods
non-hispanics who take their cues from
the electronic media are likely to
perceive all hispanics as poorly
educated semi-literate unable to speak
clear english employable only in menial
jobs unassertive and probably lazy
yet extremely prone to gang violence and
the commission of felonies with knives
positive role models portrayals which
accurately present such positive aspects
of hispanic life as strong and mutually
supportive families patriotism
often decorated military personnel and a
strong desire to be independent and
self-supporting and portrayals of
hispanic political and corporate and
communal community leaders are almost
entirely absent
i go in my testimony and talk about our
problems in trying to establish a
production center the difficulties that
we encounter
in financing both from public and
private sources
and also to thank those corporations who
have been sensitive enough to to be a
supportive of our efforts
my testimony i talk about hispanic
ownership of broadcast facilities and i
point out uh the uh the lack of of
hispanic stations
and i point out the statement that fcc
commissioner henry rivera made
that uh currently we have from about six
to ten percent that is minorities have
six to ten percent parody in ownership
and at the current rate it will be a
hundred years
or more before parity is reached unless
we do something very dramatic to change
this reality
i talk about employment
in uh in the media
the statistics on overall minority
employment are quite dismal and the
figures on hispanics are much worse
in 1982 just 4.7 percent of all
broadcast personnel were hispanic and
only 3.1 percent of officials
and managers
the policy makers of the industry
in 1974 2.1 percent of broadcast
industry officials and managers were
hispanic
if it continues to take 80 years to
increase the percentage of hispanic key
broadcast officials by 1 percent
given the rapid rate of hispanic
population growth
it may be a century before such
employment reaches parity for the
hispanic community
let me move to a
series of recommendations mr chairman
uh we believe that because of the uh
inequities and ownership and in
employment and the means of reducing
stereotypical presentation and
non-portrayals of hispanics that these
are complex and long long-term problems
and that
too little has been accomplished under a
situation
where we have a quota regulated
broadcast industry and we're fearful
that deregulation
of the blanket
nature is
is not
conducive to furthering our goals of
increasing minority participation in the
media
let me conclude uh
since i understand my time is up by
indicating to you that
we at the council are are fearful
number one that given
our lack of ownership and portrayal in
the media that a climate of deregulation
does not help us uh forward
our cause
we we are not as as our previous speaker
has indicated we do not believe that
regulation per se
necessarily
is to our advantage and that we do not
believe that regulation the more
regulations will necessarily increase
hispanic ownership and the portrayal of
the media
we we do believe that judicious
look at all the aspects of regulation
is most appropriate and that perhaps
some positive
efforts
such as those who have been discussed
earlier
might be appropriate at this time thank
you mr chairman thank you mr sagara
miss peggy sharon action for children's
television
thank you very much for the opportunity
to
there speak again
to this committee
uh i think by now you know that action
for children's television worries about
the nation's children
in terms of tv and that includes just
about every minority except perhaps the
elderly and act worries about the
stereotypic image of the elderly too as
far as children are concerned
congress and the fcc are presently
concentrating on how to deregulate
television
the major excuse for deregulation is
that alternative tv technologies can now
serve the public so well that we no
longer need to worry about limited
spectrum space
action for children's television would
like to put forth the proposition that
relying on alternative tv technologies
will mean a reduction in service to to
disadvantaged children let me tell you
why
home video recording devices in the
videotapes and video cassettes that can
be bought or rented will indeed provide
a diversity of programs for children in
those families where concerned parents
have the resources to afford such
expensive tv equipment
but those who cannot afford video
recorders and tapes who cannot afford
pay pay cable channels will have to
continue to make do with over-the-air tv
or at most basic cable
as the alternative technologies become
more popular among people of privilege
the rich the powerful the advantage will
take care of their own children and
forget about the problems of plain old
television they will not work to make tv
better serve young audiences
the problem is similar to that of
segregated schools once the rich and
powerful abandon the inner city schools
they no longer work as hard for good
education for every child
the inner city schools then are left to
decline i suggest that's exactly the
direction we're going in with television
we will have a segregated class system
of entertaining and informing children
in this country that will be a disaster
for the future of a democratic society
the major question before this body is
this
what can the government do to redress
the grievances brought about by the
failure of the marketplace to serve
minorities and children
here are five suggestions that can't be
familiar i just started
uh first
act believes the government should
encourage adequate tv service for
children and teens
television shapes the way all young
viewers see the world studies show that
minority children get even more of their
information and sense of the world from
television than white children do
any deregulatory effort relating to the
communications act and i don't approve
of deregulation but in case we're in for
it i think that the deregulation should
specify carefully formulated
quantification standards that mandate
minimum percentage time requirements for
children's television
second the government should encourage
diversity of role models on screen by
increasing diversity behind the scenes
act has petitioned the fcc to change its
reporting policy of eeo form 395 so that
every year tv stations would have to
file by job title information on race
and sex we've asked the fcc to collate
this data and to make the results known
to the public the way the fcc now
reports eeo statistics hides the fact
that television is still generally
controlled by white males
third we think the government should
encourage diversity of tv producers it
is our feeling that anything that
reduces network control helps the public
although the primetime access rule and
financial interest and syndication rule
have not made as much difference as they
should have we think the elimination of
these rules will cause the problems of
network control of tv images to get even
worse
fourth we think the government should
encourage a diversity of voices
public access cable is one important way
in which cable differs from television
public access is not only a kind of
soapbox it enables the public to produce
programs to have a voice
leased access is another way of reducing
the power of the cable company to
control the content of those 50 or 100
cable channels
new technologies can provide alternative
services
minority preference and low power is one
of the best ideas the fcc has come up
with in a long time for it can pave the
way for television that truly serves
neighborhood interests and needs
but if low power stations are allowed to
be brought up by the kinds of big
systems that now control tv the chance
for neighborhood television and narrow
casting will be lost
most important of all for the diversity
of voices is the funding of pbs the
public broadcasting service it is
outrageous that at the same time we are
deregulating and reducing service to the
public on commercial television we're
making it very hard for pbs to get
enough funds to provide diversity pbs
has developed many programs that target
minority child audiences shows like via
alegre righteous apples up and coming
and getting to know me and and used
lavar burton as a host on on reading
rainbow this summer for those of you
lucky enough to catch that show
act believes that it's important to
remember that these benefit white
audiences as well
fifth and last we think it's important
to encourage parental control
instead of censorship
we think there should be legislation to
require cable lockout devices to be
provided free to any family that wants
them so that parents can monitor their
children's viewing without impinging on
the rights of other cable subscribers
act also believes that legislation
should mandate an inaudible electronic
signal before and after children's
commercials to make possible a device to
help parents automatically turn off
children's commercials if they so desire
we're taking broadcasters at their word
when they say if you don't like the
commercials turn them off
in closing i'd like to read a quote from
high school a report on secondary
education in america released last week
by the carnegie foundation for the
advancement of teaching
quote i quote in 1981 only 52 percent of
all white families had school-age
children in contrast 71 percent of all
black and 75 percent of all hispanic
households had children in this category
of special concern is the fact that
black and hispanic young people are
precisely those with whom our schools
have been least successful
unquote
while we get on with the important work
of improving our nation's schools let us
consider television as an important
partner in educating all the nation's
children the benefits will accrue not
only to blacks and hispanics and other
minorities but to every child in the
united states of america
and i would like permission to
put in the record
acts handbook fighting tv stereotypes
and a study that act commissioned called
images of life on children's television
sex roles minorities and families by
professor ephrel barcus which was just
published last week just in time for
this hearing
without objection those materials will
be included in the record
the chair would now like to recognize mr
edwards who is president of the
hollywood chapter of the naacp
thank you very much mr chairman for this
opportunity to
be represented and heard once again but
before i get started
in an order protocol i'd like to
thank my congressman mr waxman for being
here
as we do work very closely on these
issues in california
as of this moment yet another generation
of our nation's children is growing up
with the same negative images
of people of color that has been the
standards throughout the history of the
television industry
often the only thing that edged out the
negative portrayal of minorities has
been other extremes of the industry's
employment casting practices that have
has allowed no images at all
in the case of on-camera portrayal
it is more the rule than the inception
that people of color will be limited to
rose
as
sidekicks helpers or comic relief
to understand the root cause
of the problem
at least two factors can be noted
access to closed society of executives
is disproportionately limited to
white males who today
as in the past
are
of such an overwhelming majority in the
television industry as to negate the
livelihood
that a proper appreciation of talent and
abilities of minorities can be sought
this same fraternity justifies the
absence of positive
plentiful starring roles for minorities
by inferring that viewers would turn
away from such portrayals
despite the fact roots is still one of
the most watched television production
in our history
programming practices when we would like
to thank our past
and gone
are still with us
these practices we feel
must come to an end
as ha as has become the custom for tv
guide
their september 10th issue highlights
many of the new shows for the current
season
with all due respect to the actors cast
in the various roles
whose abilities we are not questioning
one can still nonetheless shed light
on some interesting factors
of those members of the new shows
pictured 17 of the 26
are all white
only eight of the 103 actors pictured a
minority
7.7 percent
it would also be appropriate to inquire
why minority roads are limited to
a boat
attendant
on the mississippi
the boss's assistant
a black genie to a white master
a sidekick to a computer whiz kid
and a sidekick
as a staff sergeant as opposed to being
a captain
please take note
that there are no hispanics or native
americans who are cast in any roles
whatsoever including asians
in addition to which
although
none of the
aforementioned minorities are featured
as the lead
minority americans have constantly hoped
for non-minority americans
would come to understand that this great
nation
is ours
could be
even greater
if the sick minds would not
were not allowed to continue to obstruct
the pro progress that can be achieved if
we work together
all the while that we have been hoping
and waiting for improvement
in program contact
the realization that we could
take steps to speed up
rethinking
process that our tv executives must
undergo
has been
discussed and suggested more than often
please be advised that the minority
population in this nation
and in itself constitution economic ebb
and flow which
far exceeds an entire national budget of
whole countries elsewhere in the world
many of the products advertised on our
airways
owe a significant percentage to its
profit past present and future by the
buying power of those americans who have
to this point
refrain from any organized economic
muscle
flexibility
the exclusion of minority enterprise
and interests
must come to an abrupt end
this demand has not
come too hastily for we have waited
and it
and for we have waited
it's us not unworn
for we have been portrayed unfairly
this demand is not unjust it's the fact
speaks for itself
the
the minority entrepreneur who has sought
to supply the network with programming
can account only
for
0.008 percent of prime time
hours in the past 15 years
quoting the carew rainbow report march
1983
as to this fact
that 188 hours 72 percent of comedy
musical variety shows 88 hours of flip
wilson 18 hours of red fox 22 hours of
bill cosby variety shows five hours of
motown music specials and one hour from
the diana ross entertainment
there are children growing
up in this country
without reinforcement
of their history
without reinforcement of who they really
are and it's time that we brought that
to an end it is time for us
to stop playing games
and putting up which hysteria
stereotypical uh images that are
portrayed on our airwaves of which the
public owns it is time for
congress to do something about it and
follow through on what legislation they
do pass thank you
thank you mr edwards uh the next person
we'll hear from will be mr
mcdonald dr mcdonald i'm sorry
from uh
northeastern illinois university
well mr chairman and
gentleman of the subcommittee i thank
you very much for this opportunity to
testify and i respectfully request that
my written testimony be entered into the
record
i come here today not as a tv snob who
wants to attack television and secretly
foster a new appreciation for classical
music and shakespearean drama and maybe
even reading i come here as a qualified
friend of television i grew up on it as
most of us in this room probably have
i like much of its product i certainly
appreciate the potential that it has as
an informational and entertainment
medium but i'm also painfully aware of
its shortcomings particularly in respect
to its treatment of minorities and
specifically based upon the research and
writing i did for my book blacks and
white television
in television's attitude toward
afro-americans
i understand the mechanics of television
they are the mechanics of business
they work with demographics they work
with bottom line profits
and they worry about attracting the
largest possible
audience the fact that it is a triopoly
television is dominated by the cbs nbc
abc
triad
because it is such we are really
competing for one one-third plus of the
audience thus broadcasting has within it
certain inherent problems in terms of
the representation of minorities
i understand all this however and then i
look at black america
if afro-america were an independent
nation
it would be based upon its gnp the 23rd
largest country in the world
there are 170 independent nations black
america will be number 23
so it is rich
and yet it is not served it is also big
if it were an independent country it
will be the 30th largest country in the
world
these are the things that television
executives tell us they really
appreciate demographic size
and financial wealth
we also know that blacks are brand loyal
more than whites who run off to their
generic and house brands blacks buy
sponsored products
they watch more television
proportionately than white america
so what is the problem they seem to fit
into all the mechanical structures
given all these qualifiers is it not
reasonable to expect television to
provide honest well-rounded authentic
and plentiful representation of
afro-americans on network television
should a consumer force richer than
nigeria portugal argentina or israel not
anticipate programming as authentic and
ennobling as these nations provide for
themselves
should a demographic unit which is
larger than australia
the republic of china taiwan
not anticipate that its tv programming
will project honorable images of its men
women and children in exactly the same
way such programming exhibits white
americans
and if it were to appear anywhere on
earth
would we not expect it to develop in the
united states of america a nation
founded upon principles of human dignity
and human worth of equality freedom and
the like
now in our understanding of world
politics we would expect the communist
russians
to portray capitalistic americans
negatively in their national television
we would anticipate white south africa
to ridicule its subjugated black
nationals
on the television programming of the
republic of south africa
why should abuse of racial or economic
minorities occur within the united
states of america on network television
stereotypes are an integral part of the
history of america the minstrel show in
the 19th century brought us the toms and
the coons and the mammies and the
pikaninis and the bucks and all those
derisive images that white america
needed to justify its subjugation of
black america how else can you justify
the treatment of a human being unless
you ridicule him so much in your culture
that you know he's less than you he is a
childlike and until the independence
after the civil war then he became a
rascal adult a fool someone had to be
looked after those images still
refashion stylize modernize are what we
see on television we get the wild animal
that mr t presents as b.a barakas on the
a-team we get the hip-flip wise guy
wisecracking imagery that rochester
brought with jack benny and everybody
senses all white america's always found
lovable the norman lear bud york an
empire a liberal empire is based upon
minstrel stereotypes over and over there
was a time
at the end of the sixties when it wasn't
that way
television has shown that it can produce
imagery of blacks that isn't racially
derisive
there were mod squads and julia's and
bill cosby's in room 222's that gave you
much more honest representation but
they're dead
with the white backlash with the racist
reaction of the late 60s they have died
with the presidencies from nixon through
ford and carter and especially with
ronald reagan
where
these kinds of attitudes apparently have
been given their head
we see even less dignified
representation
now hispanic america may have a bleak
situation but it has foreign language
programming it can draw from peru
argentina mexico the soap operas that
populate so much of uhf television in
spanish language channels but where is
black america you can't take a nigerian
program or ugandan program and put it on
expect afro-america to understand it
white america has deracinated cut the
roots off of black america and now will
not even allow them to see themselves
regularly and honestly on television
if we are to understand
the legislative direction that you might
want to direct your energies i would
point to two
first of all as white america moves with
its affluence to cable and other uses of
the video screen computers video games
black america is going to become
proportionately a higher percentage of
the free television audience surely
network executives will appreciate that
advertisers will understand that already
we can see in certain daytime soap
operas that kind of breakthrough why not
in dallas falcon crest dynasty and all
the other great shows of the evening
and secondly once we do have cable once
inner cities have it available big
cities don't have it yet it's mostly a
white suburban phenomenon
when the big cities have it then we can
have many channels then we can have
narrow casting and just as narrow
casting destroyed the racism of
broadcast radio
narrow casting television can hold
potential to destroy the racism that is
there in the triopoly of present-day
network television
thank you
[Applause]
we welcome you here mr torres and
thank you for your participation
thank you very much mr chairman for the
record uh my name is arnaldo torres i'm
the national executive director for the
league of united latin american citizens
the country's largest and oldest
hispanic organization
we very much appreciate the opportunity
that this subcommittee provides us with
and coming to you today to discuss
access to the media
by minorities
there have been a lot of interesting
points made especially by the
the previous gentleman the doctor
mcdonnell who i have some disagreements
with
but we can get into that right now
with regards to uh the media with
regards to the media
the power of the media is a tremendous
power
it is a uh better yet it is the it
provides the future for whether our
society understands what is around them
uh presently and whether they can adjust
to what's going to be around them in the
future
therefore a household spending
as much time as they do before a
television tube
it will reflect more or less the way
that an individual or household will
view that society as the nation's
fastest growing minority in the country
the portrayal of hispanics by major
networks will have a direct effect on
ensuring that the hispanics receive
equal protection and equal justice
provided by our laws the negative role
given to hispanic actors and actresses
further ingrains the stereotypes that
exist in our society further these
negative role models provide bad
influences on hispanic children to
follow as they grow and strive to become
productive members of our society we
have a number of studies that we've
attached to our
testimony
on one of them it was a study on march
23rd 1983
of the 17th program chair wants to thank
you too mr dr mcdonald and the chair
would like to
admonish the audience that
demonstrations are not allowed in the
committee hearing
but the chair does respectfully
understand the applause
chair would now like to recognize mr
arnold taurus who is with the league of
united latin american citizens
we welcome you here mr torres and
thank you for your participation
thank you very much mr chairman for the
record uh my name is arnaldo torres i'm
the national executive director for the
league of united latin american citizens
the country's largest and oldest
hispanic organization
we very much appreciate the opportunity
that this subcommittee provides us with
and coming to you today to discuss
access to the media
by minorities
there have been a lot of interesting
points made especially by the
the previous gentleman the dr mcdonnell
who i have some disagreements with uh
but we can get into that right now
with regards to uh the media with
regards to the media
the power of the media is a tremendous
power
it is a uh better yet it is the it
provides the future for whether our
society understands what is around them
uh presently and whether they can adjust
to what's going to be around them in the
future
uh therefore a household spending uh as
much time as they do before a television
tube
it will reflect more or less the way
that an individual or household will
view that society as the nation's
fastest growing minority in the country
the portrayal of hispanics by nature
networks will have a direct effect on
ensuring that the hispanics receive
equal protection and equal justice
provided by our laws the negative role
given to hispanic actors and actresses
further ingrains the stereotypes that
exist in our society further these
negative role models provide bad
influences on hispanic children to
follow as they grow and strive to become
productive members of our society we
have a number of studies that we've
attached to our
testimony
on one of them it was a study on march
23 1983
of the 17 programs
that were
surveyed by
corpus christi state university that we
requested to do a study of the 17
programs prime time 9 out of the 263
characters per trade were hispanic
excluding hill street blues hispanics
equaled 5 out of 232 characters per
trade hill street blues on nbc accounted
for 44.4 percent of the number of
hispanics portrayed on television the
percentage of hispanics and major roles
was 2.2 percent two of the 92 two of the
uh 0.92 hill street blues and nine to
five which is on cbs
four out of the nine were minor roles
two were cooks on archie's place one was
a made on dallas and one a gang member
on hill street blues i think the
congressman from dallas texas would
would confer
would confirm our contention that in
dallas it's pretty hard not to see a
hispanic walking the streets and in
dallas i think we're more than just
maids but if you watch the dallas
program
we're lucky if we're a maid we're not
even ranch hands and so they've even
negated the stereotype that everybody
has of hispanics as being farm workers
or farm uh or out in the migrant fields
in a study in 1991 conducted by public
advocates for lulac of the three major
networks only one percent of the
characters presented were hispanic 37
out of
3546 only 11 hispanics were allowed to
speak even one word almost two-thirds
who spoke
seven
or 11
were portrayed as negative or criminal
roles all hispanics portrayed by abc for
example were portrayed as inmates at a
prison system
it is conceivable that these negative
roles could have been avoided had there
been hispanics as key making positions
within the network's hierarchy but
hispanics are hard to find we have
another study that goes over the three
networks insofar as they're hiring of
hispanics and i won't go into great
detail i think it's all self-explanatory
what is disheartening about these
statistics is that these networks have
offices and cities with heavy
concentrations of hispanics and numerous
hispanic media organizations
nonetheless it would be unfair for us
not to say that there is some progress
being made
last year and about this time the league
supported the repeal of the syndication
rule in an attempt to show our good
faith effort to work with the networks
to try and improve their ability to
portray hispanics on and off the camera
in a much better light
that effort on our part
bore very little fruit
in fact some of the people in fact mr
gary heimel who worked for the speaker
of the house at one time representing
the networks
indicated to people of the network uh
network world that the hispanics were
sewn up they were in our pocket
they were going to support the
syndication rule
while the league will be announcing in
october the first somewhat of a
different perspective on that position
and
based on a study that we will be
releasing at that time will indicate
exactly why the perspective has somewhat
been altered but it's important to
understand and when you look at the
media the media industry is like
president reagan
in just beginning to discover hispanics
it's really very interesting there is
some progress being made however mr
reagan and other public servants are
held accountable every four years or two
years whatever the elections may be in
those state local or federal areas
the media industry unfortunately only
becomes much more insulated every year
there is no eeoc laws covering them in
all honesty in fact with all due respect
to the members of this subcommittee
those of you who are freshmen those of
you who are only first or second year
members of this subcommittee this
congress has been totally irresponsible
and really going after the media and
making sure that is doing a better job
of trying to hire hispanics of trying to
hire other minorities and of trying to
make sure that they portray minorities
and women in a much more positive and
true light
and it is not necessarily an indictment
that i make of this subcommittee or this
congress but nonetheless
there is some
lack of aggressiveness
that has not come from
this body
let me give you a couple of really good
examples of the progress that the media
feels they've made
we had the opportunity to meet with one
of the networks and their vice
presidents in new york after having them
go to a media conference in california
in which they were exposed to a number
of hispanics at the local level there in
hollywood
we met with them about two months
afterwards and they told us that
progress had been made when we asked
them how many hispanics they had hired
they could not tell us that because they
didn't break those statistics out we had
the vice president in charge of
management and affirmative action there
but they did tell us in programming
progress had been made for when they
make television movies they encourage
their producers to shoot minorities who
may be out in the general area so they
encourage them to shoot them as extras
see that's the sensitivity that the this
one network had another network when we
called them up and asked them why they
haven't shown any hispanics on well for
example good morning america their
response was to tell us that they were
going to have jose feliciano on the
following week and was that hispanic
enough for us
yes ladies and gentlemen
progress is being made
but progress through the eyes of people
who really do not understand minority
america or have no desire to truly
understand the predicaments that they
put
us in
but just to look at the electronic media
and exclude the print media as analogous
to covering a ruptured artery with a
johnson johnson band-aid for just like
producers and directors writers
reporters and editors are biased and
very and view life with a cultural stand
they write what they know feel and sense
while hispanics represent eight percent
of the population they represent 1.3
percent of the reporters and editors
working on the nation's general
circulation dailies
it would be ideal for us to rectify the
exclusionary practice in the electro
electronic media through reason versus a
legislative solution
we hoped through our meetings with the
networks
for over a year that that progress and
that effort would be accomplished
in the event that legislation is needed
our concern is that an administration
such as the present one
would only de-emphasize
the corrective effort that this
legislation would try and have
in conclusion mr charles erickson of the
hispanic link news service stated it
best in a 1982 article for prospective
magazine on hispanics in the newsroom
although it refers to the print media it
applies here quote it should come as no
news that with its broad first amendment
protections the press has awesome powers
in our society reporters editors and
publishers decide what and who makes
news and because they are overwhelmingly
white males these decision makers have
with notable exceptions led newspapers
to present distorted views of minorities
and women we would make the following
recommendations in an attempt to deal
with the uh
creating more access of minorities to
the media industry and that is that this
subcommittee
conducts thorough investigations of the
industry and its discriminatory
practices of persons on and off the
camera of minority backgrounds
that this subcommittee seriously review
and alter the role of the fcc in dealing
with minority access to the media
industry
and third that certainly pbs should be
strengthened but let's not put anyone in
the media above anyone else pbs sure
they're the liberal group
they're the ones that
as uh saturday night live says are
competing with nbc and have changed
their colors
but they too have a heck of a lot of
problems when it comes to hiring
hispanics a lot of problems and all you
have to do is talk to some of those
people over there
and they'll hang up on you
if you don't agree with what they're
saying
so let's not uh let's not color anybody
better than the other this industry is
in need of a major
major alteration and let's not stop
simply with the networks we've got to go
to the studios
we've got to go to the advertising
agencies
no one is above improvement certainly
not in the media industry
i thank
the chairman and the members of this
subcommittee and i'd like to make one
last point the gentleman
to my right indicated that hispanics
have
spanish television
and that that is a reasonable
alternative to our programming
well if
that there is another alternative in
other words
i think to some extent there is
there is somewhat of an alternative as
compared to what the black community has
but let's not give that
let's not have that be a reason
for not moving as aggressively
in dealing with the networks in the
studios with regards to their inability
to deal with minorities especially
hispanics let's not have that
let's not have any studio let's not have
that be an excuse for any network not to
address the problem so i thank the
chairman a very good person who is
concerned about hispanics since he has a
lot of them in his district and i very
much hope that i can come back to him in
the future and discuss this and other
issues before him thank you very much mr
chairman
thank you
chair would like to remind the audience
that demonstrations in the committee
hearing
room is
are not allowed but the chair again
acknowledges that he
appreciates what the applause represents
let me assure mr torres that uh that
indeed this commit the the congress
might not have in the past move very
aggressively on the issues that we
discuss here today
but uh
since my arrival on the
telecommunications subcommittee i will
assure the gentleman that indeed this
committee
as well as the congress will move as
swiftly as as it is that we have and can
muster the kind of
influence with the congress as as
possible
i would suggest to you that all of the
members of this subcommittee who are
here present
have a stated
expressed interest in
the issues that we discuss and are very
much committed
and are now very aggressively committed
uh to doing all that's necessary to
affect some real changes in the in the
areas that we we're talking about
uh
let me throw out a question to all of
you
the minority community has a gross
national product well in excess as was
alluded to by dr mcdonald in excess of
150 billion dollars
the black community in the united states
has a larger population than the total
population of canada
for well over 10 years minority rights
groups and community organizations
including some of those who are here
represented
have exerted pressure on hollywood to
restructure the
the industry to resolve the problem of
underrepresentation and
misrepresentation of minorities in the
media
given that we appear to be
regressing rather than progressing
in the communications media
what can the minority community do
to exact some positive change
in other words you
being the representatives of the
activist organizations
and
an intellectual involved in analyzing
these circumstances what is it that you
feel that the community at large can do
to bring about some change
well i'll respond very quickly since
we've been doing a lot of these things
now um as i indicated in the testimony
when we took the position on the
syndication rule we had hoped that
the good faith effort would reflect
would be clearly reflected and expected
or
responded to uh in kind by the uh by the
networks we launched uh the national
media watch campaign in which we form a
local media consoles to monitor the
local affiliates and see just exact
exactly what type of record they have
often on the camera of hispanics
we attempt to be very reasonable in our
first attempts we try to sit down with
the national as well as the local
affiliates networks to discuss ways of
improving making improvements
institutional improvements affirmative
action things
opportunities for producers development
of hispanic programming et cetera
at this point we've reached a a
a level where um
the discussions are no longer going to
help we filed a charge stomach charge of
discrimination against the networks in
october of last year and we hope that
that charge is going to bear fruit in
the very near future but i think that in
view of our reasonable attempts to deal
with the networks and to some extent
with the studios
the only alternative now is to really
hit him in the pocketbook
and i think that that's about the really
unfortunate only alternative that
minority america really has because i
don't think that you can really reason
with these people
and i think what we intend to do is to
pursue a much more of a legal approach
of filing lawsuits against them
dealing with
with cable television and making sure
that the networks don't
don't are not allowed to get involved in
things that would only expand their
sphere of influence and at the same time
ensure their same practices
we're going to be doing a lot of these
types of things and we have up to now as
much of the
press coverage press attention given to
to what they've done as many reports as
we can do at least maybe one every six
months
measuring whatever progress
nbc
officials tell us that they have been
making progress
and with all due respect to nbc i would
have to say to some extent there is but
cbs tells us that they're going to put
one hispanic on the air next week or
next year uh and so we're supposed to be
happy with that
yeah i don't know what these people
expect from us i mean do they expect us
simply to say thank you very much then
we're going to go home and and that's
all over um i don't really think they
understand exactly the fact that we want
institutional change and not uh and not
uh and not simply just an immediate uh
you know gratification gesture but those
are some of the things that we believe
would be helpful and we think eventually
they will prove to be very very
beneficial thank you mr chair you ask
about what the public can do what can
citizens do for 15 years act has been
talking
about the problems of children's
television
to the networks to the industry
to parents
and to to the government and through two
republican and one democratic
administration people were listening a
little bit
uh even in the nixon administration we
had dean burch talking at industry
meetings about the needs of children as
a marketplace failure but with the
reagan administration what's happened is
that the swords of damocles at the
regulatory agencies that are supposed to
make the communications act work the
communications act that says
broadcasters are supposed to serve the
public interest those that sore those
swords have been turned upside down uh
this administration seems very
interested in other kinds of weapons but
but when it comes to the weapon of
enforcing the law in this particular
area
we find that because of the regulatory
attitude in washington because the the
need is to regulate on the side of the
industry that nobody really wants to
listen to the consumer anymore
the you can't hire children to do
children's programs it's okay on access
channels but it's really not the way to
do uh programming uh at a national level
so you can't fix it by getting children
in there and uh
the
the fcc
which
is really the place to go if you you
want change from the industry if you
want that act enforced has been behaving
so badly that act sued them in fact next
week on wednesday our suit is going to
be heard in the court of appeals and who
knows maybe that'll cause somebody to
listen but if the regulatory agencies
don't listen if the white house doesn't
listen then the industry has big parties
to celebrate what they're doing with
children's television with minority
television and they ignore everything
that's happening on that screen
yes i'd like to just um add something to
to what peggy has said in terms of the
need for levers and the need for
regulation in the process and i think i
can speak for several experiences that
we've had at citizens since we've been
litigating on behalf of citizens and
consumer groups since the late sixties
and i'll give an example of a regulation
that is no longer in place that was
dismantled because the administration
said it didn't work but give you an
example of how it worked and that was a
top 50 market policy which provided that
a licensee who could not own more than
three television stations in the top 50
markets and the concern was the reach of
potential audience and because the
commission regular agency granted every
waiver that was brought to it by
licensee the the commission said it
didn't work but something happened
because it provided a lever for citizens
groups at the local level to negotiate
with broadcasters and hit their
pocketbooks because legal fees had to be
paid if the suit was not negotiated in a
way that that could allow them to
address specific needs i can recall one
agreement that was was negotiated with a
saint louis broadcaster as a result of
the top 50 market policy and as a result
of that agreement
agreement that particular station which
it had problems in its eeo profile
negotiated an agreement which meant that
it would go to parity
uh parity not the 2550
percentage in in its its workforce there
was a concern too about using minority
women as twofers so to underplay the
minority count we negotiated an
agreement that provided only a
percentage of women minorities could be
double counted there was a concern the
station told us that they did not have
qualified minorities and women to do
programming in production and therefore
part of the the agreement was not only
with the particular station provide more
public affairs but it would also permit
at least a couple of shows to be
provided by local programmers and make
its equipment available the key to this
is that the public interest standard and
the regulatory framework that flows from
flows from that can work if the
regulatory
regime in washington is sensitive and
and broadcasters know that there is some
accountability and the levers are in
place and the kind of assistance is
provided to citizens group to make the
act
the act work
thank you establish
you want to give something
well uh
as i understood your question is what
would we like to see i would just like
to see some honesty and carrying through
of the regulations that we're supposed
to have
and and and to be able so people won't
be so confused of how you really get to
get to the fcc
and how do you get some action on an
issue i think if we go up against a
station like in los angeles
well it'd take almost a year and a half
before you get an answer back and so by
the time you
get the answer back everything is
defused
when we hear from the stations in los
angeles when they get ready for their
license to be renewed
and and and the basis of it is i think
that for us as minority groups if we
were all to come together
and go in instead of being separate from
each other
but work with each other and be a force
and let the networks
know
that no longer will they keep us divided
by playing games and be able to go in
and get what we all want together and
represent all of us instead of one being
over here and the other one being over
there
uh because that is what's kept us
divided all along and i think the other
thing is is i think that when congress
makes
regulations and pass laws i think these
laws should
be a commitment by congress itself to
make sure that it's carried out and the
regulatory agencies such
as the fcc
should be one that is independent
not
bowing to any administration
because communication of the airways is
very very important it affects all of
our lives
dr mcdonald
um i think whatever
could be done must take into cognizance
the bottom line again this is a business
and it's also a business that is fraught
with lots of dangers because we're
talking about free speech and we're
talking about the government's role in
free speech and and what all
however i think that whatever is decided
upon should take into account the
financial aspects of television i would
argue for laws for instance permitting
tax breaks for the hiring of minorities
perhaps the being the ability to write
off minority salaries for the first five
years
something that would make it encouraging
for networks to
purchase in a sense the labor and skills
and abilities of minority workers
i would argue also that
lobbying efforts although they have a
chronic history of failure
could nonetheless be much more
substantial
if they pointed out the importance of
black viewers
as i suggest in my written report and in
the oral delivery blacks are becoming or
minorities for that matter are becoming
an increasing proportion of the
television viewing audience because
whites are moving to alternative uses of
television they're using cable mds dbs
video games video record recorders and
what all and with cable mostly in the
white suburbs we find then that more and
more the audience is black 25 percent of
the viewing audience of daytime soap
operas is black female
result we have several programs with
very
different roles for black actors than
have been traditionally there
roles that are still not viewable in
prime time however
i would argue then also that polls could
be commissioned
developed to show the importance of the
consumer force in the demographic force
of minority audiences i would suggest to
the organization of the black viewership
or minority viewership so that it could
become an important force especially
minorities who are on nielsen homes
one nielsen home is worth you know
hundreds of thousands of
non-nielsen homes
i would also argue that minority actors
could be organized to protest
demeaning roles not only to protest
roles that aren't there but those that
are there
i would also suggest political pressure
organized pressure placed upon
candidates for the 1984 presidential
election
perhaps the election of jesse jackson is
the only answer but i think that
the other white candidates republican
and democrat could feel the heat
of organized protest and bring to the
office in 85 a new attitude
particularly an attitude toward the fcc
where it seems now we are selling my
birthright the birthright to the fact
that the people on the airway is not a
couple few companies
however that too goes with a new outlook
in 1985 either from the re-election of
the incumbent or from the election of
a new
man in the white house we still could
bring pressure through organized
political efforts so i think that in in
terms of persuasion but also more
importantly in terms of bottom line
profitability
the
situation could be brought home more
strongly than it has
mr chairman i would like to ask the
gentleman a question did he mean that if
i were to go to work for a network i
would get a tax rate
the network would your salary perhaps is
an example your salary could be written
off for five years so it's an incentive
to hire you
assuming that once you're in the door
for five years working that you will
have proved your worth and therefore be
retained
so i do get a break tax break too
no you would pay your taxes like anybody
else but the network would in other
words be able to depreciate uh your
service as much as baseball players are
appreciate depreciated by the team
owners
chair would like to recognize mr gala
thank you mr chairman i have a
few uh suggestions number one it's been
our experience that there are
precious few opportunities for hispanics
to receive training in the media that
we're all totally dependent on the
on the networks and a few of the
stations
secondly we
lack researches
on the untoward effects of negative
stereotyping on our on our self-concept
we have approached nimh on a couple of
occasions and asked them to undertake
this research and they've indicated they
wouldn't touch that with a 10-foot pole
i think we need to take greater
advantage of the license renewal
challenges
we need to look at
capitalization ownership is really one
of the major keys you can do all you
want to around the edges
and be on the outside trying to look in
and trying to make some changes from the
outside but it's been my experience that
when you're have ownership that that is
by far the most effective way of
bringing about some change so we need
the small business administration to
focus much more on minority uh financing
of radio and television uh by uh by
minorities uh we need uh we need
enforcement we need these kinds of
hearings and we need the greater
enforcement by
particularly in the civil rights area as
you know there's been a conflict as to
who has authority eeoc or the fcc or on
who has jurisdiction on civil rights
enforcement i think that that ought to
be um settled and that there will be
some very aggressive enforcement of
civil rights provisions
mr chairman can i make just one question
ms cook
i'm sorry ms cook
i just wanted to say that that that
my organization would look very very
negatively upon any kind of tax credit
for any network
who hired a minority
i don't think under any circumstances
should somebody be given a tax credit
for doing what they're supposed to be
doing and doing what's the right thing
to do based on merit
i just don't think that our organization
would under any circumstances support
that
and i think the other point is that a
lot of the responses have been with
regards to government regulation
um there's only so much the government
regulation is going to be able to do
and i think that dr
mcdonald made a good point about the
economics of it
what you're really looking at is that if
minority america ever can get well
organized enough
to
conduct consumer preference viewing
that will make the change all the
government regulation in this land is
going to have some impact to some extent
but it will never have the impact that
consumer preference viewing would have
on the networks or even on the studios
so that's really what it all comes down
to until we had to get to that point
where somehow the networks become very
benevolent we're really never going to
see really major changes but clearly
that should not refrain your leadership
from doing everything it can to
aggressively go after the networks and
try to bring about improvement but i
wanted to make those points because i
thought they were very important to be
made at this point thank you
miss cook
i just like to echo
the point that i think minority
participation is a valued participation
in any um
sense that tax credits would be given
simply because one is a minority in hire
to do a job i think would create and and
indeed reinforce the kind of stereotypes
that that are here about minorities and
capabilities and so forth i'd like to
just address one thing in terms of what
the subcommittee's
role might be and i think i would
emphasize your oversight function that
is important even as regulations are
implemented to keep an eye on what's
happening and to be prepared to change
or eliminate things and i'll give you a
couple of examples for one in the area
of ownership which i see is key to this
issue and um in in grave danger i think
the the the this particular submitted
subcommittee should be concerned about
the chairman fowler's um public
statements that minority preference is
unconstitutional i think that's that's
key to to ownership and and it is the
policy of the of the nation and also the
commission i think concerns that have
cropped up from and signals from the
commission in the context of cases such
as rivers broadcasting in which the the
chair and then commissioner sharp
indicated that minority ownership
preference should be tied to a
substantial presence of minorities in a
community rather than being a good in of
itself and when one thinks about the
fact that minority by def definition
means that one will not be a substantial
presence in a community it seems to wipe
out minority preferences i think another
question might be looking at the area of
extending minority preferences and
ownership to the new technologies one of
the difficulties has been that the new
technologies tend to be common carrier
kinds of technologies and the link prior
to this has been programming and and and
therefore ownership but the new
technologies and new carrier systems are
where the the future action will be and
we need to examine the philosophy and
ways of dealing with that kind of
question and extending tax certificates
to that again i think um your um
substantial efforts in dealing with
questions of eeo at the commission
internal eeo and external eeo uh demand
and require continuing oversight by by
this committee and i think to the extent
that the subcommittee
keeps the fcc accountable that will be
the extent to which broadcasters during
this regime will be accountable to the
american public the gentleman with
gentlemen yield just briefly
jump from washington
ms cook makes a very important point
when she says we should be concerned
about the fact that chairman fowler
believes that pursuing certain of these
things would be unconstitutional but it
might be pointed out for the record the
chairman fowler believes a great number
of things are unconstitutional
that many others including the united
states supreme court do not find
unconstitutional law
thank the gentleman from washington
would like to now recognize the
gentleman from california mr waxman
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to commend this panel i think you've
done an excellent job of
outlining the the concerns you have and
the concerns we share with you which is
the reason for this hearing i also want
to pay
recognition to my constituent mr edwards
and tell him i'm pleased he's here i
noticed mr chairman you have others of
my constituents who will be testifying
later unfortunately i'm going to have to
leave i have a conflict in my schedule
but i i want to welcome them as well and
i'm i'm
aware of what they will be testifying
about
i've had the opportunity to hear them in
our los angeles hearing and i'm pleased
that
at that hearing when they requested that
we have a hearing here in washington
that the chairman of our subcommittee mr
wirth and mr leland working with him
we're able to
accomplish this this meeting today and i
hope it's the beginning of not just an
accomplishment of a hearing but further
accomplishments to try to deal with the
problems outlined i just have one quick
question i would address to the
maybe
dr mcdonald because he's raised this
issue
when we look at
something like the voting rights act
we see
a great success story because we see
that when blacks are participating in
the electoral system
politicians white and black respond to
that constituency
now television is a business
and television stations and networks are
out to make money
when
we realize as you pointed out the
financial clout that black americans
have
why why wouldn't we expect them to
respond to
that financial clout
and if they're not responding to it
how can
citizens
bring across the point that there is
a reason for them in an economic sense
to respond to those concerns of the
minority community
well of course the reason they are not
responding to it is that it is
uh black america is swallowed by the
larger white american percentage of the
national
gnp
and therefore
what is
astronomical in terms of world gnps is
relatively small relative to
the total american consumer force
however
i think that private groups
can become much more effective in terms
of raising the consciousness of
black
viewers or minority viewers for that
matter
in terms of arguing with substantial
facts statistics not just rhetoric not
just pleas to moral decency that doesn't
work with absolute statistics that hey
look there are 35 percent of the viewing
public of this particular program
are minorities why don't we have
more minority imagery or when there have
been positive images of minorities on
television we see that the ratings were
such and such why don't we have more of
that and this kind of argumentation
could be directed not at the networks
necessarily alone production companies
ad agencies sponsors uh ratings
companies all of them are part of the in
industry and uh but i think there's
purely a persuasion of morality of
decency is a whistling in the wind
as the the business interests whisk by
you have to speak their language and
because it is an industry
that involves free speech
we have to be very careful about just
how far government goes
because a perhaps most of us in this
panel would enjoy a liberal government
in its uh utilization of clout and power
and control of television but what
happens if a conservative a reactionary
government you may not like that but
you've already set the precedent you
must be careful there's one source of
accomplishing objectives but societal
pressure outside of government is
another and it seems to me that we have
to explore both avenues with the
sensitivity that we do have a a
constitution that guarantees free speech
and we want to be very careful not in
any way to eliminate the protections
that the constitution affords us
i i would just maybe in a rhetorical way
say that
if we have spanish language stations
that attract many of the hispanic
community i think that's fine
for those who wanted to be able to opt
to special programs but i would hate to
see the day when
we're going to have
television for
blacks
television or hispanics television for
upper upper middle class whites
etc etc because i think it's as
important for the minority community to
be fairly represented for their
self-image
but i think it's even more important for
the majority population to get an
appreciation of what all our people are
like in this country and if we only
watch each other ourselves on a special
television programming we we get a wise
our population in a way that destroys
the the diversity that this nation has
which enriches all of us and i
and i just mentioned that point uh not
particularly in any contradiction to
your
assertion that hispanics do have that
option i think that's not a sufficient
option nor would i think that you have
to think it's a sufficient option but i
i i i think it's important for all of us
uh those in
racial majority of those in minority no
i totally agree with you i suggested
that if the hispanic situation was bleak
at least there was that alternative
relative to black americans
there was not even that alternative and
of course cultural apartheid is not the
answer uh cultural ghettoization is not
the answer however
i wouldn't call cultural apartheid or
ghettoization the narrow casting of
television that is the ability to appeal
with 40 50 100 different channels to
one tenth of the audience rather than
with three channels through the networks
the way they now exist to one-third of
the audience that is really the hang-up
above all is the fact that you have only
three companies that control all of
television they only own 15 stations but
their shows are on almost every vhf
station in the country and their reruns
or state shows that pass through their
portals are on almost every channel in
the country so that is really that the
major problem is that you have to get
one third of that audience when you only
have to get one eighth of that or one
tenth of that audience or one fifth or
one percent
then we can have
a whole station for just jazz a whole
station for just uh cooking a whole
station for uh whatever types of
programming well i thank you very much
for your your uh response to my comments
and i
as the chairman of this committee knows
and other members know as well i've been
a very strong opponent of the of the tri
tribe monopoly or tri
what is it
of the three networks and
have championed the the at least the
limited
rules that we have now in place that
keep them from
even further
bringing under their control television
programming and i think a great deal of
our problems is due to the fact that
we have the three networks the dominate
that seek not to try to bring about
these other public interest concerns but
just to sell products and
i find it
something that we have to acknowledge as
a reality and something we shouldn't
succumb to or acquiesce it thank you mr
chairman i appreciate the recognition
and i again commend you for holding
these hearings thank you
chair like to recognize the general from
texas mr bryant
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to direct my first question to
ms cook
you may have adequately answered this
question already but it's there's been
so much testimony i didn't pick it up
exactly what i
want to ask you and that is this
there have been an awful lot of
criticisms directed today all of which i
agree with the broadcast industry
we've mentioned
a poor enforcement a poor effort on the
part of congress and so forth to address
these problems my question is this
is it your
group's
feeling that the existing statutes and
the existing regulatory scheme
are sufficient to eliminate the problem
we're addressing today if they are
that scheme is adequately enforced or do
do you advocate
additional changes in our statutes
additional changes in the mandate that
we've given to the fcc or anything else
in addition to what we have now
i i think that there are different
aspects of the problem that that i can
the statute addresses and then it does
not
for example in the area of minority
ownership
i think the key there is not
necessarily amending the statute i think
the statute is adequate the key there
may be being concerned about ownership
restrictions
i think the congress could make efforts
in in the area of tax policies to
provide incentives i think you can use
the tax statutes in order to provide
incentives and that would be the way of
addressing in another substantive area
some of the pr capital problems that are
present in in in terms of um ownership
opportunities in the industry if you're
looking at questions of portrayal i
think that there we do come into some
difficulties in terms of first amendment
kinds of issues and and the question is
how do you deal with that area without
coming in in contact with with the first
amendment i don't see
regulation direct regulation in terms of
content regulation there but i think if
you increase the minority ownership if
you increase employment uh possibilities
that those will react
and respond to
to questions of imagery in broadcasting
but it has to be a a a pretty aggressive
kind of situation there may be other
areas that that are not as directly
related i i think i would go off in
terms if you're thinking of tax credits
what we've looked at are tax incentives
um in in terms of tax certificates i'm
sorry in terms of transfers there might
be tax credits in in the sense that if
one does a training program of some sort
that there
there is clearly a kind of nexus between
employment and what the government pays
in terms of unemployment or retraining
which is is a part of the national
experience so i think that there are
other ways to to look at at particular
issues i would emphasize structural
regulation i think in the area of
children that their content and direct
regulation is important because they
have no marketplace power and so you
have to perhaps mandate um well do you
would you agree with mr dr mcdonald that
congressional policies that uh
encourage the multiplication of
channels and
is
something that's going to advance the
inclusion of more minorities and
programs not necessarily i think it it
has a potential i think for all all of
us there is a potential in how it is
regulated and how it is the incentives
will make a difference in what happens
for example i think as peggy has pointed
out to deregulate on the assumption that
there is a plethora of video outlets
would be a mistake most of them exist on
paper a lot of the the video kind of
possibilities we talk about are will be
tied to income and therefore they will
be available to portions of our our
society and not others the others will
have geographic concentration for
example we talk about cable as if it is
everywhere and yet it is less than 35
percent penetration so first of all
where will they be will they be
profitable will they come into existence
i think the next question is who will
own them if we remove all the ownership
restrictions then
the diversity that we think will occur
may be replaced by the same player
stronger and more integrated coming into
the marketplace and therefore you may
have
the same kind of programming
possibilities that we enjoy today and so
i think there has to be structural
regulation
in order for what we assume to be a
marketplace to work and therefore i'd be
very concerned that new players come
into the industry rather than old
players extending their their presence
ms jaren did you want to answer that
question also i agree 100 with with
wilhelmina and i wanted to point out
since
chairman fcc chairman mark fowler was
mentioned
that in addition to his other
ideas about unconstitutionality
he thinks that pbs can do it for just
about everybody that television isn't
doing it for now
and uh that's
it's nonsense i mean they couldn't if
that's what they were supposed to do
only serve the disadvantaged and the
unserved there's only one spot on the
dial there's only one button
sometimes two in a marketplace but
rarely i think montana still doesn't
have a public broadcasting station but
they can't do it for everybody all the
time uh
and and we keep talking about networks
but we should remember that that law
applies to every station each and every
station in the country and that each
station if they were doing a job there
would be a diversity the the other point
i agree with is about cable cable is
already disappearing as a diverse uh
mechanism for bringing the thousand
flowers blooming to the public it was
more diverse a year ago than it is now
and i think we may already have lived
through the golden age of cable
programming not services there will be
additional services banking and shopping
but as far as programming is concerned
the usa network for example did away
with a really delightful diverse
film program that took film from all
over the world and ran it for children
at six o'clock at night i noticed in the
trade press that they have just bought a
hundred hanna-barbera off-network
cartoons that's going to do a lot for
diversity for children in this country
chair would like to recognize the
gentleman from california mr moorhead
thank you mr chairman
i wish to thank the members of the panel
for their presentation this morning you
certainly have
pointed out a very serious problem that
we all need to work on
recently there's been a a ruling
by the commission which
would tend to
lead towards
the control by
the network of syndication
and we're concerned that they may go
further in this direction do you believe
that in view of the record of the
the networks and minority employment
that this would help your problem if
they would be able to
have a greater
greater control over the syndication of
programming and
thus a greater control of over the
programming itself and the production
i would say no
i don't think so if they're not going to
do it now would you think they'd do it
then and syndication they want to take
control of syndication because they
don't have control of syndication now
that's how some programming get gets on
air
say for instance
with the beverly hills hollywood naacp
we do the image awards every year
we finally figure out a way that we
couldn't get it on network prime time
so that if we raise the money ourselves
from
private industry we'll be able to
syndicate it for the first time in its
15-year history last year we did
syndicate the naacp image awards and the
positive feedback that we got from that
is now we are looking at negotiations
with
a major network from prime time for this
year so therefore we have been trying
for 15 years to get on and finally when
we just decided to go on and raise the
money ourselves and hire syndicated to
syndicate the show uh we ended up now
we're negotiating with a major network
possibly to do the entire show
i i agree i think that that uh
anything doing anything compromise of
any kind with those um
financial interests and syndication
rules now is a mistake i notice the
networks are right here in in tremendous
attendance i think c-span must be the
only uh cameras in the um in the
courtroom it's it's my experience that
uh or the hearing room it's my
experience that that the
three networks do not put issues about
about television on the air
and
they
they
try to keep the public from finding out
what communications issues are important
today and i think that possibly those
issues are the most important thing that
this country better deal with and nobody
understands that nobody understands that
the broadcast spectrum is like land in
this country it's limited and you can't
just open your own broadcast station and
that's why we make rules and i think
that to expect the networks to start to
serve minorities well if they if they
have a re uh a release of those rules
now is is
preposterous look what they're doing for
children the fact that nobody is putting
pressure on them means the children's
programming is disappearing off the
network except on saturday if they
wanted to stop a rule like that now one
would have thought they would have done
better service at least for the year
before they made the point
i might just add that uh
usually on communications issues i can
move with fervor and passion in a
particular direction and i can on this
one i do believe that the syndication
financial interest rule should be uh
maintained i don't think the networks
have yet explained why those rules have
prevented them from hiring more
minorities and women and women as
producers and i think that is one of the
issues at the same time there's a great
deal of concern that i think will be
presented by subsequent panels
first-hand accounts of what the
independent producers have done and they
have failed to
attract and to hire
minority producers and also to present
present programs that reflect more
positive images of minorities and women
in our culture now if there's it seems
as if they're saying well the networks
won't show it and the networks seem to
be saying that they don't present it and
i think that this is a situation in
which the question of concentration may
control the issue and therefore any
attempt to enlarge the network's power
on this i would think would be as long
as you have a greater diversity
diversity in control of these pro this
programming though
isn't there a better chance for the
minorities to
to be able to
be a real part of it and to produce the
shows themselves and to be able to
control some of that
some of the programming
itself more than if you turn it over to
networks where where you uh well i think
there are two things one as long as
there is some opportunity for the
independent producer to be profitable
then there is the possibility that that
diversity can can happen i think the
other thing that is important the
financial and syndication rules is that
i think it has made a difference for
independent stations to be able to have
off network programming and on this
particular issue i think the health of
the independent stations is is
particularly germane and how you come
out with the calculus
tenses are the same the bottom line is
the same it's just a matter of who's
going to make the money
when independent syndicators have been
in control there has been no appreciable
difference in the portrayal of
minorities than when they weren't in
control but i think what is missing here
is a political sense there is in
politics a quid pro quid and if you're
going to give up something something
should be demanded in return and perhaps
here is the crux of the matter if indeed
there is going to be a switch to allow
networks to
control
greater portions of the revenues of
reruns then let's get something from
them in return
not let's not just give away the candy
store
and perhaps that's then the ultimate the
bottom line on this particular measure
mr moorhead
your question
is very interesting especially for us
since we went through an extremely
interesting adventure for a year
last year about september at this time
in october the networks uh came to us
that asked us to support the repeal of
the syndication rule
always telling us that
that if they had done to assure blacks
and other minorities that their problems
will be seriously and properly addressed
fifteen years have passed since the
kerner commission identified factors
which contributed to race related urban
unrest in this country because of the
media's failure to communicate the needs
and concerns of black people
if we fail in 1983
to correct these ever-present unfair and
sometimes illegal practices
blacks and other minority victims will
only become more and more disillusioned
such
callous willful disrespect and unfair
treatment by the telecommunications
industry may not by itself cause a long
hot summer
but it could bring about a long cold
winter
in which blacks and other minorities
combine their resources collectively
deciding not to patronize the film and
broadcast industry collectively deciding
not to support those advertising
sponsors
there is a growing suspicion in the
minority community that a conspiracy
exists among the producers networks and
studios to exclude minorities from fair
and meaningful participation in motion
picture and tv programming
we therefore call for an investigation
to expose and in
this destructive and insidious practice
in conclusion we hereby urge this
committee to pursue the enactment of
legislation
guaranteeing that a fair
and equitable allocation of a portion of
the dollars spent
for the creation of programming
be allocated to contracts
with minority owned and controlled
production companies
gentlemen i thank you
mr hoax mr casey
imagery
is information
the perception of misinformation always
brings about
a misperception
the dissemination of ill-perceived
information begins to foster a
collective ignorance that is devastating
in its contemplation
proper imagery is proper information
ill-perceived imagery is misinformation
and the lack of imagery is just as
harmful as ill-perceived imagery
because in both instances they are lies
and lies most certainly are
misinformation
harmful in their content
and unmistakably wrong in their intent
when i was very young i was taught that
it is not right to tell a lie
that was proper information
but what i could not comprehend was that
in many instances those persons who
espoused that position
were in themselves liars
and that seemed to me to be a serious
breach of integrity
even at that young age i could deduce
that lies and integrity were not
compatible
it is perhaps the lack of integrity that
permits people to exist in the dark
corridors of mendacity
and mendaciousness
is all that we can perceive as we watch
the kinds of programming offered us
particularly as it deals with minorities
i am sure that there are those persons
in the entertainment industry that enter
their job place with their integrity
intact and their intentions good
however
there is a peril to residing in babylon
and that is the distinct possibility
that one will become a babylonian
someone once said that all that is
needed for evil to succeed is that good
men do nothing
i do not support a position that the
kind of programming we have to digest
is evil
it is not evil in its intent but it is
desperately evil in its result
because it is full of misinformation
and mendacity
we of the community of color
come to those persons in decision making
capacities
time and again
with our hearts thumping full of promise
and our bosom full of possibilities
we come to those persons earnestly
hoping that their integrity has not been
injured
and that they will stand fast as good
men as just men
as men who stand for fairness
men who will accept their responsibility
to the viewership to not abuse the
imagery of people of color
each time we stand pregnant with
anticipation of how things ought to be
and those men continue to give us the
collective mr t
we have no intention of swallowing the
old bromide that is just entertainment
we as people of color cannot afford the
callousness exercised upon us
by insensitive people making decisions
that are thoughtless but hardly thought
provoking
decisions that are careful only in their
exclusion of people of color
decisions that continue to perpetrate
the kind of imagery that warps the
psyche of the viewership for generations
it is said that lies will die their own
death
and the truth will live forever
that phrase is obviously pre-media
it had to have been said when people
continue the oral tradition
because we have all witnessed some lies
in the media that have refused to die
the lie of misinformation
the lie of misrepresentation
and the lie of underestimation
the media has continuously
underestimated the intelligence and
endurance of the viewership as they
refuse to accept the responsibility for
their deeds
there is a serious lurch in the
collective integrity of people who make
decisions in regards to people of color
on television
if you feel this is a fallacious
statement
you simply need to watch a few nights of
entertainment
via that electronic telecommunications
phenomenon
the tube
the tube that programs us whether we
want to be or not
you can witness for yourself
i speak the truth
the longevity of the misinformation
has such catastrophic possibilities
as to be terrifying in the extreme
the incessant
insistent unyielding redundancy
of the kinds of images we confront
simply has to be addressed
it has to be addressed by the people
responsible for it
just as we have to address the people
responsible for it
some good men must come forth some
strong men
some men with integrity
to say simply stop it in the name of
what is right stop it in the name of
what is fair stop it for the sake of our
children stop it
image
imagery imagination imagination should
be the springboard
to enlightenment
and the image the wellspring of truth
what better way to bring about
enlightened understanding than that of
proper imagery
what better way to lessen the anxiety
and fears of those who are represented
and those who are not
than by proper imagery
what better way to undergird the
slipping sense of well-being of a people
made desperate by a society that does
not seem to care
than that of proper imagery
what better way to show the world that
many kinds of people do exist
than to tell them the lie that they do
not
than by proper imagery
it does not take magic
just imagination and commitment
it is not an act of god that television
is so white
it is a conscious decision made by white
men
who think the world is all white and
refuse to understand that it is not
things can change things have to change
and they will change if those persons in
decision-making capacities
embrace their own integrity and come
forth for what is right come forth for
truth
good men strong men righteous men
in the face of this need i recommend by
this committee
a full-scale investigation into the
tawdry hiring practices of this industry
the minority community is suspicious of
a conspiratorial effort by networks and
producers to exclude them from the
workplace
and urge the passage of legislation
guaranteeing a substantial and equitable
allocation
of the dollar spent by the industry to
be contracted by minority owned
and controlled companies for the
creation and production of product
i gave you now my colleague in
continuation miss sumi haru
mr chairman members of the subcommittee
i am here to place before you my
concerns as a person of color and a
woman
i wept the day my daughter told me a
classmate of hers wished he weren't
filipino but would rather be white i
still cringe when my mother tells me to
stay out of the sun because i'm getting
too dark
and i am filled with sadness every time
i see an asian pacific american trying
to emulate the white standards set by
the media
the medium you are considering is one of
the most powerful educational tools in
the world
it is estimated that the average family
watches six and one-half hours of
television a day which means a young
person may spend more time with a tv set
than he or she does with parents
teachers or clergy
a distinct distinguished actress and
fellow national board member of screen
actors guild janet mclaughlin and i did
a study for our ethnic equal
opportunities committee to see how much
influence television has on individuals
perceptions of others
among the organizations participating in
our experiment were a predominantly
media minority media class at california
state university of los angeles
this green actors guild eeoc
in dallas
federally employed women
service employees international union
los angeles county commission on the
status of women asian pacific american
women's conference coalition of labor
union women and the los angeles basin
equal opportunity league which is
comprised of affirmative action officers
of major corporations
we asked the participants to assume the
position of chief creative officer of a
network with complete creative control
in such position they were asked to cast
actors of their choice or highly visible
people such as elected officials
in a new prime time series called mo
hollywood method of operation hollywood
the cast consid consisted of criminals
prosecuting and defense attorneys a
police officer the officer spouse and
child a drug pusher a drug addict and
the proprietor of a an adult book shop
neither sex nor ethnicity were specified
for any of the roles
in every session the participants cast
the series exactly as the networks or
independent producers would
75 percent men
25 percent women 90 percent white and 10
people of color among their reasons for
casting this way were this is what they
thought the public would like to see
or they never thought a prosecuting
attorney
being a minority woman or they just
didn't know any minorities to put in the
parts
it appears the public is being
brainwashed
seldom do we see on the screen a
minority woman carrying a briefcase an
hispanic elected official
a native american indian doctor or next
door neighbors who are people of color
seldom do we see ourselves portrayed as
an integral part of the american
mainstream
perhaps this is why the asian pacific
americans often hear
my you speak perfect english how long
have you been in our country
clearly the stereotypes on the screen
are superimposed in real life thus
preventing asian pacific americans from
reaching upper management levels perhaps
the bombardment of caucasians on the
screen prevents our children from
developing a positive self-image and
instead makes them wish they had blue
eyes and blonde hair
the most famous asians on screen are
still fu manchu and charlie chan both of
whom keep reappearing in updated
versions and still played by whites in
yellow face
these characters are not our idea of
positive role models
another contributing factor for the
non-existence of people of color and
particularly minority women on the
screen is a survey known as the tvq
which ranks performers on their
visibility
there are approximately 900 living
performers on the list plus athletes
howard cassell
cartoon characters and animals
if one does not appear on the tvq they
are most often not acceptable for major
roles on television people of color
seldom have the opportunity to become
visible enough to get on the q list
this form of discrimination is not
unlike a blacklist
our unions and our communities have been
appealing to the industry for years to
bring our reality to the screen but we
have been met with deaf ears
we are sure that if more of these
decision makers were people of color our
concerns would be more readily heard and
understood we have sat through numerous
meetings with decision makers presenting
our statistics with everyone shaking
their heads and agreeing how poor the
statistics are and making promises to do
better we have negotiated affirmative
action into our creative unions
contracts but still no positive change
has been made since the mid seventies
and unfortunately gentlemen in too many
areas there has been a retrogression
complaints have been filed with the
equal employment opportunity commission
against the three networks and their
producer suppliers but those complaints
are gathering dust and cobwebs not being
pursued and the staff members refused to
respond to claimants phone calls and
letters
it is hard to imagine why people of
color should continue to consume product
which fails to reflect them
a conscious effort was made to change
textbooks to show more than white mommy
and daddy spot in the picket fence it is
time for the television industry to
acknowledge its consumers
in order to accomplish a change we call
for an investigation to expose the
suspected conspiracy between the
network's producers and studios to keep
people of color from fair and meaningful
participation in the television and
motion picture industry
and in conclusion we hereby urge this
committee to pursue the enactment of
legislation guaranteeing that a fair and
equitable portion of the dollar spent
for creation of programming be allocated
to contracts with minority owned and
controlled firms
thank you and now my colleague mr
esparza thank you mr sparser
mr chairman ladies and gentlemen
members of the subcommittee i am honored
honored to be a part of a panel with
such great american artists
my name is muktizuma esparza
i am a native of a community a few light
years east of hollywood and called east
los angeles
during the 11 years since i graduated
from ucla's master's program in film and
television i have been often cited as
one of the exceptions
a chicano who has achieved a measure of
success in the entertainment industry an
emmy a cleo
an academy award nomination
the president and owner of three cable
tv companies
producer of a feature film currently in
theatrical release by a major
distributor
the tragedy is that i am the exception
and yet my achievements are modest
this should not be the case in an
industry where there have always been
men and women
of vision and courage
individuals who understand and accept
the moral and ethical responsibility of
the pervasive power of film and
television to mold and shape public
opinions
values and morals
i am unable to read into the hearts of
the leaders of the studios networks and
ad agencies who wield the authority in
our industry
i assume that they are men of goodwill
i say men because there are no women in
these posts
unfortunately the composite of their
wills is manifest as an industry
that is unwilling to change
the few improvements the industry can
cite the creation of some horizontal
integration in the trade and craft
fields
some public affairs programs
were and continue to be the result of
minimal
government regulation
yet no hispanics are employed as staff
writers by any of the networks or
studios
no hispanics are employed in a position
of even marginal authority
in any of the program departments of the
networks
or story departments of the studios
no hispanic is employed
in any position of authority or
responsibility in any network or studio
with the exception of the area of
governmental relations and public
affairs
and that's only at one network
my colleagues tell me that there are
five black decision makers in the entire
industry
and we know of no asian or american
indian executives
there are no hispanic producers working
for a network program or for a studio
there are three black producers working
for network shows
only one in a dramatic series and none
for a studio
so long as these truths continue our
country cannot begin to address the
moral decline in the quality of our
entertainment
how can we enrich the lives of the
children of our country if what they see
on the screen does not reflect the
reality of all of america
and what they do see
appeals to our baser ins
instincts of sex with violence
not until there is also vertical
integration in all areas of management
will blacks asians american indians and
hispanics who are 30 percent of the
entertainment industries marketplace
then see themselves represented on the
screen
and in
roles
the core of the problem as i have
experienced it
is the almost total absence of
minorities in the executive suites of
the networks and studios
not to mention the boardrooms
minorities in the entertainment industry
are not asking for reparations for past
injustices
we are part of the economic fabric of
america today
and are entitled to share and
participate in the rewards
not just the risks
because we have talent and ability and
something to offer
our industry needs help not only in
adjusting the economic interest of
networks and studios
but also in bringing equity to the
millions of blacks
asians american indians and hispanics
whose future is the future of america
there is a strong suspicion in the
minority community that a conspiracy
exists among the producers networks and
studios
to exclude minorities from fair and
meaningful participation in motion
pictures and tv programs
we call for an investigation to expose
and end this despicable and insidious
practice
in conclusion i also urge this committee
to pursue the enactment of legislation
guaranteeing that a fair and equitable
portion of the dollar spent for the
creation of programming be allocated to
contracts with minority owned and
controlled production firms
thank you very much my colleague mr
carter
mr carter
distinguished members of the
subcommittee
the recent 20th anniversary march on
washington
provided us all with not only a reminder
of how far we have come since those
early days of the civil rights
struggle but it also gave us a chance
for new commitment
in the struggle to achieve full
inclusion into the american system
there have been in industry and society
measurable gains
though so much more is yet to be done
as a result of that struggle of the
sixties and seventies
americans of all colors
have won the right to eat together
to pray together
to sit together to live side by side
anywhere in our nation
the right
but not the opportunity
black and brown political gains have
been just this side of miraculous
when one considers how minorities were
previously systematically shut out of
the processes of government
decision-making
today
minority americans are wielding a share
of power and responsibility in many
areas of commerce and industry
except in hollywood
despite what you may have heard to the
contrary
racism is alive and well in hollywood
with very few exceptions
minority producers and would-be network
and studio executives of color
are shut out of the system
the vast majority of actors directors
and writers of color
seldom work
on the rare occasion when they do they
are usually hired for less money than
their white counterparts and the
assignments they are given are usually
second string
the perspective hollywood reflects of
america and the world is a white
perspective
reality tells us that there are asian
lawyers native american engineers
latino neurosurgeons
and black astronauts
but hollywood tells us there are not
reality tells us that washington dc is a
multi-racial city
but a television show a soap opera
called capital
shows us a whites whites-only
perspective of the nation's capital
talk about fantasy
the television and motion picture
industry
is out of step with reality
i believe that there is a solution to
this situation
one that is based on an accepted
precedent
one that can provide new opportunities
for creativity as well as for profit for
all concerned
last month
president reagan signed an executive
order designed to increase opportunities
for minority entrepreneurs
that executive order requires each
federal agency to create and implement a
minority business enterprise development
plan it was apparently a follow-up to mr
reagan's earlier declared objective to
assist minority entrepreneurs to help
build a strong economic base for the
nation
i submit
that a similar plan
could work wonders within the
telecommunications industry
a minority business enterprise
development plan for the television and
motion picture industry
with the guidance of your committee and
a redirected fcc
the industry could be encouraged to set
aside a portion of its revenue for
reinvestment
with minority producers
please note that i said reinvestment
i am not speaking of a handout but a
handshake
investment holds the potential for
profit
this kind of set-aside having ample
precedent in government procurement
history could nourish a generation of
entrepreneurs and creative artists who
might offer the industry much needed
enrichment
last tuesday sylvester pat weaver former
president of nbc in an address to the
hollywood radio and tv society
called for major innovative changes in
network programming
or else the networks quote
are going to be in terrible trouble
end of quote
well
we would like to provide that innovation
we minority producers directors and
writers would like to help the networks
retain their audiences and resist the
onslaught of the new technologies
we offer them the opportunity for an
infusion of cultural cultural diversity
new ideas and new product
the inclusion of minority producers
directors and writers could be a major
source of the urgently needed innovation
of which mr weaver spoke
i believe mr weaver is correct when he
warns of terrible trouble in store for
the networks
i believe we are moving closer and
closer to a consumer rebellion against
the put down and shutout that blacks and
other minorities are made subject to by
the networks and studios
many americans are fed up with what they
see as a conspiracy to retain the last
major bastion of de facto segregation
prime time television
what if one day all the black and brown
television viewers in america and their
white supporters were to stop watching
tv to demonstrate their discontent their
outrage over the way minority people are
put down or shut out when it comes to
the casting of dramatic roles on
american television
what if millions of minority consumers
and white sympathizers were to turn
their backs on the television screen for
a whole month
what if that action were to mushroom
and extend itself to bypassing a select
list of advertisers who support those
network programs
how would it affect the sale of
television sets cars soap
cornflakes soft drinks
beer
fast foods
how many millions of dollars would be
lost
is this what it takes to get a measure
of justice
fair play
i know that there is another way
every sound business reinvests a portion
of its earnings to stimulate more
business new products new markets with a
view toward increased productivity
what i am suggesting is that minority
producers who have been heretofore
excluded from the mainstream
become the industry's new products
division
that the industry make a commitment to
sit down and negotiate a formula whereby
the major producers and the networks
create a partnership with a community of
minority producers for the development
of innovative product
this could happen with your help
the industry could be induced to commit
contractually a portion of their
revenues to finance the development and
production of movies and television
programs
produced by the native american asian
latin and black communities
sharing in the promise as well as the
profits derived there from
perhaps significant lasting gains can be
made for all concerned
we urge you to investigate the
possibilities
we don't need another committee report
to tell us how bad off we are
just look at the statistics
ask how many minority producers
directors writers
cinematographers musicians
and network and studio executives there
are
by now it should be clear to all of us
that the industry will not change on its
own
we therefore urge you to provide
leadership on this issue we urge you to
help create a constructive dialogue
between the industry establishment and
the minority communities a dialogue of
negotiation
we urge you to pursue the enactment of
legislation which will guarantee a fair
and equitable allocation of programming
dollars to minority producers
i submit to you that this is the only
way to bring about fair treatment of
minorities
on the screen
and behind the scenes
in the telecommunications industry thank
you
thank all of you for your
very uh wonderful testimony you have
provided
mr potter
uh due to the lateness of the hour the
two of us must be off to try and catch a
plane
uh the the others
will
represent us in any questioning that you
may have
comments you may want to
elicit from us thank you very much for
your participation and leadership on
this matter thank you so much
[Music]
the chair would
like for the gentleman who have to leave
to know that the record will be open for
any further comments that you might have
and there might be an opportunity for us
to to give you questions so that you can
respond and that too would be a part of
the record
mr carter
in a recent article you were mentioned
as one of a number of black actors who
has become a tv director
is this a reaction to the lack of
quality roles for black actors or is it
an attempt to increase minority
participation behind the scenes
well i'm speaking for myself on this
issue as you as you asked me to
i recognize that there are many
minority actors who have become very
frustrated
waiting for the telephone to ring
waiting for someone to decide to begin
with if they'd like to have a minority
person play a role
and then
it filters down to the idea of calling
that particular actor
it is true that
my
experience in this industry
leaves much to be desired
i came off of
a series my third series
in 1979
i was doing battlestar galactica then
having already done the phil silver show
on cbs and
mcleod on nbc battlestar galactic was on
abc so i had done all three three
networks
i came off of that series
feeling pretty
high and uh confident that my career was
on a very
steady
level
in march of 1979 that's four and a half
years ago
in the last four and a half years i have
worked a total of three
weeks
as an actor in four and a half years
now
and one of those three weeks i employed
myself because i'm also a producer
now i'm not saying this because i have
sour grapes or because i am
i'm trying to evoke your sympathy but
but you did ask me a question and i'd
like to respond to it fully
i think that my my fate is not
unusual because i have many friends who
are better actors and actresses than i
am
who work less than i have in the
industry
uh it occurred to me long before i
got to that gully that i find myself in
that
if i'm going to have any kind of control
over my destiny as a human being as well
as an artist
that i had better become a producer and
a director that the fact is that i had
aspired to to move in that direction
anyway
and when i started my company i was in
the middle of the series mcleod and i
found myself doing both things at the
same time because they were fulfilling
needs of mine
fortunately for me i've been able to
make a very good living as a producer as
a director and part of the reason
incidentally i part of the tribute has
to go to the federal government for
having a minority
set aside program because i as a
producer was able to take advantage of
that
in as much as there was very little
opportunity for me as a minority
producer in the private sector but the
minority set aside development
programming a program called the 8 a
set-aside program
has has enabled me to gain a great deal
of experience and also to survive as a
human being in my craft at my craft
and i this is why i am so confident that
uh that this that the success of this
application
can can
bring success for us in the private
sector
unfortunately the
the evils the weaknesses of the
set-aside program have been given a
great deal of publicity i have seen on
60 minutes the uh the bogus presidents
of companies who happen to be in our
minority with the companies are white
who didn't even know the addresses of
the of the offices of the companies that
they work for
but i must tell you that there are many
of us out here who are hard working who
are sincerely minority producers and who
are attempting very hard to become
competitive in the private sector
i have just finished producing a
television series that's going to be on
pbs
but i'm still trying to get at that
with the networks and the and the major
studios
i hope that answers your question sir
well it does
let me just ask you if you can briefly
do you believe that uh well
you would rather
well i guess you you you enjoy doing all
of what you're doing producing directing
but uh is is acting a greater passion
for you
is it that you want to be seen or
i'd just like to see what what it is
that that you choose to do and what
you're you're least allowed to do sir i
consider that a very personal question
but i will attempt to answer it i
i think that
that
i am most fulfilled when i'm able to do
many things and i think if i were given
an opportunity to
to work as an actor in a very
challenging role that i might put
everything else aside and deal with that
challenge because i find that that's the
only one that i the way i can move from
one day to the next to deal with the
challenge at hand unfortunately i have
not been offered any challenging roles
so i'm not saying i haven't been offered
any roles i mean every actor has to
be selective in what he or she
pursues and i have been offered roles
that i turned down in the four and a
half years but
nothing of substance nothing meaningful
is offered to me and for the most part
is not is not offered to my compatriots
mr hooks uh last year network had
sophisticated gents a program which
dealt in a mature and adult manner with
black life
it's my understanding that filming of
the program was completed a full two
years before the show was aired
and that the network did not actively
promote the show at the time it was at
why was the show
on the network shelf for so long before
it was aired
well first of all congressman uh it was
more like three years from the time we
finished shooting the film
until the time nbc decided to take it
off the shelf incidentally it's the
first time they've ever kept the movie
any movie on the shelf for that long
sophisticated gents was a story not a
comedy but a dramatic portrayal of nine
black men very strong very
sensitive middle class upper middle
class lower class
black men
and their wives and their families and
the stories were dramatic the stories
made sense they were uh
the characters were were very very fine
characters for the most part
it appears that uh the networks uh
did not uh could not deal with the the
uh the dramatic uh uh aspects of the
show
uh
there were no buffoons there were no
comedic characters they knew this of
course when they shot the movie but
uh melvin van peeble's deal with the
networks uh was that they would
make the movie
uh and they would air the movie but
there was no time uh element involved my
estimation is is that they uh
is that they the the characters were
were powerful and positive and and in my
experience
uh
as a an actor
and a producer in the industry
uh the networks uh for some strange
reason
uh are uh
afraid uh for lack of a better term
to
to to put those kind of characters into
their uh regional uh affiliates uh and
and i think that they had a lot of
feedback negative feedback
from the movie in that sense so it was
just kept on the shelf until uh the
administration changed and when the
administration changed
they had gotten so much heat from
the
from the public
mainly the minority public to release it
that
the the new president uh grant tinker
then decided to
to release it
there was another film that was that had
the same uh kind of history and that was
maya angelou's
sister sister
which they kept on the shelf also for
over two years
i don't know the real reasons i can only
speculate that
they had problems dealing with their
affiliates in the south and whatever and
it tends to play a
large role in the release of black
material
thank you
mr rue
are there
or is there an abundance of asian
pacific actors actresses writers
producers directors
are they available to work and just
aren't working
there are definitely
a great number of asian pacific american
artists
i i represent an organization called the
association of asian pacific american
artists which is comprised of people
like jimmy hong
and mako and beulah we have writers
producers directors
i do it um
and i happen to be one of those
fortunate ones that has a
job we're there but we're not part of
america
whenever we're seen in in a script there
usually is some dialogue from another
character explaining
why an asian pacific is in that scene
it's just not taken for granted that
we are americans and we sort of just
belong here and no explanation need be
given
we have in the writers guild very few
asian pacifics
um we have very few asian pacific
directors in the guild
and we have very few
producers who are actually producing
for the networks
but they are there and they're trained
and when there is work available it
won't be as though they just came out of
the woodwork they've always been there
they just haven't been exposed
mr esparza
you talked about having won i think an
emmy uh
nominated for an oscar
and uh i forget all of the other
awards that you received but
and you talked about how you have been
the exception
i have uh about 30 of my my district is
is uh is chicano
uh and i've been working to try to to to
make sure that hispanics as well as
blacks are elevated to
equal citizenship with all americans
in terms of full participation and
opportunity etc
i find it amazing
that having watched and having been a
moviegoer to some extent but having
watched television that there is little
or no participation of hispanics
behind or in front of the cameras and i
will go back to the example of dallas
that was used earlier
where i watched dallas only a few times
myself but i've been it's been brought
to my attention that
people have watched it
over and over again and have never seen
one black or one hispanic in the movie
in the tv series i was also reminded by
there was a group of kids black kids and
i think one or two hispanics had gone
with them
they had gone to israel
and they come back and they were they
were responding to questions from a
group of people who wanted to hear about
their experience
and this
one of the black kids was asked
where they were from this was in israel
i might add
and one of the black kids was asked uh
about their experience and and in
america and that kind of thing and then
somebody had the right idea to ask them
where they were from they said they were
from texas and they were from houston
not dallas but they said well you
couldn't be from texas because we
watched dallas
in israel
and all we see are white people there
so how is it that you can be
from texas
anyway i i've seen very few movies
produced uh that had chicanos in there
and of course uh chico and the man i
think was the only hispanic and i'm not
sure that uh with chico uh chicano he
was a puerto rican puerto rican which is
a puerto rican hungarian
puerto rican in hungary but anyway i've
seen very little evidence that uh there
is
uh uh
and
any preponderance or any any abundance
rather of actors and actresses or maybe
even on the other side the writers and
producers and directors of hispanics
there is a tremendous abundance of
hispanics who are actors musicians and
directors and writers in los angeles
alone there are four theater groups made
up of hispanics who mount plays and have
regular seasons
and basically do this because they
otherwise would not be able to practice
their craft at all their art at all
hispanics have been knocking at the
doorsteps of hollywood
and not just solely because we wish to
be a part of the industry but because we
probably comprise 50 of the population
of the actual town of hollywood
and
have been a part of this country since
before the country existed
i often get asked where was i born in
mexico
and i tell them well no i was born in
los angeles
and my wife who is also a chicana her
family goes back in this country for
about 400 years in new mexico
so we're definitely part of the
landscape and
find ourselves unable to have any access
in hollywood the few
successes that i've had in my career
have been the result largely of the
affirmative action pushes in public
affairs
the documentaries that i produced at won
the awards
and public broadcasting the feature film
that is currently in released was
originally
underwritten by the endowment of the
humanities
and the corporation for public
broadcasting and american playhouse it's
called the ballot of gregoria cortez and
it happens to be the very first film
that has ever been on public
broadcasting and then considered good
enough
by a major hollywood studio in this case
embassy to go into theaters and it's now
in release and doing well
the screenplay was available for the
studios and for the networks before we
made it for pbs
but at that time
the
answer that i got was that it was just
not something that was considered
commercial they didn't think it wasn't
good
they thought it wasn't commercial that
hispanics the minorities are not
commercial
thank you mr espresso let me i'm going
to have to leave in the chairs going to
going to assume the chair the wheelchair
let me just say something you know we we
were discussing a minute ago uh
the absence of the commercial tv
stations and uh here today and it's
rather
an incredible
uh acknowledgement i might add the fact
that uh
that that we had such a broad array of
personalities who have been deemed you
know especially in the minority
communities but even in the general
broad community at large
uh people like mr hooks and
and mr carter of course and mr poitier
and mr casey i'm
i mean names that people automatically
flinch at when they hear them and there
has been not one commercial tv camera
here in this room had this been
a hearing where alan alder
or one of your white counterparts been
here there would have been probably all
kinds of television stations
available here i understand that a
couple of networks were represented here
uh but it
it amazes me
that
maybe it's because it's the it's the
criticism that you're you're conveying
here that they don't want america to
hear i'm happy and proud of the fact
that c-span is here however because it
does i think c-span covers something
like 15 million homes in america and the
word is getting out
thank god for c-span but but it really
amazes me that the the networks did not
see fit to come and cover what it is
that you had to say today
that's going to be everlasting in my
mind mr mr carter
congressman with your permission i'd
like to make a comment that occurred to
me when you were talking about dallas
i have learned as some as you may have
too that dallas is a very popular show
in other parts of the world it is very
very popular in all corners of africa
and in europe and probably in many other
if i might interrupt you i was in in in
zimbabwe recently and i wore i have a
cowboy hat a straw cowboy hat
and some of the kids would run up to me
and say yeah
oh god
well that's interesting they do watch
dallas yeah somewhere well you know that
has both
positive and negative ramifications
when people
in other
lands
see the america that is portrayed on
television
just think
of what a hard job it gives our state
department what a whole
our foreign policy has to dig its way
out of because what we're saying to
those people in all those lands the
majority of the world who are not white
is that you really don't count in
america
even though we have black and latino and
asian and native american people in the
united states they are just not
important enough to put on shows so we
can depict a city like washington dc and
call it capital or dallas
and we will
work around very easily those people who
happen to be of color
how do you think
a nigerian
or a person in zimbabwe or in
sri lanka
responds to that they may not respond to
it verbally but it makes our task
of making
those people in those nations think that
we are
guardians of democracy it makes our task
even more difficult so
what are talking about here is something
which damages all of us as americans
we've talked about some other aspects of
it but i think we should also look at
that too we have a responsibility now if
the airwaves do belong to the public as
has been said and as uh
chairman wirth has said on on numerous
occasions
we've got to protect those airwaves
because those airwaves speak to us they
speak for us and they speak for us to
other people we've got to think about
every manifestation of every image
that's on the air now none of us
certainly wants government supervision
or control we certainly uh
cherish freedom of speech
but there are limits to freedom of
speech too
such as the old
proverbial
yelling fire in a crowded theater
and i think that we can find parallels
that can make us recognize that we need
greater
oversight on the part of the
fcc and more important the congress our
elected representatives to make sure
that our airwaves are responsive to and
responsible to the public
thank you let me say before i leave that
uh first of all mrs collins from
illinois
would have been here but she just she
had she i think she's in route from her
district as a matter of fact and
expresses her her regrets for not being
here she is very much involved in this
issue she is a member of the committee
and is
has offered her leadership already since
she's been on the committee and as a
matter of fact is holding uh not a
hearing uh just like this but similar to
this on friday doing
as a part of not only the official
uh
congressional hearing but also part of
the congressional black caucus weekend
that you know is coming up
i want to thank all of you personally
and say to you that i hope that my
colleagues will address the issue of the
conspiracy that you raised because i
heard each one of you you say that at
the end of your your presentations and i
think that that's a very interesting uh
perception if not the reality and i hope
that they further
endeavor to pursue that issue thank you
very much mr chairman
uh
if we're to address the problem that we
all agree exists and i think everybody
you're
to some extent with this committee we've
been preaching to the choir this morning
because most of us came here with
a similar view of the circumstance that
you have
most of the solutions that have been
mentioned this morning relate to
encouraging minority ownership
of
i guess
production studios
or of
of the broadcast outlets themselves and
i wonder
in view of the various levels at which
decisions that are discriminatory
are made
if
simply addressing ownership is enough
all of us up here i believe have
have
are co-sponsoring legislation presently
to try to encourage
more minority ownership
of those two
different entities but i wonder that's
all that i've heard discussed this
morning i wonder if that's enough
it would be very hard for us
to own a network
let's be realistic gentlemen
it's very difficult now when you look at
the us commission on civil rights
statistics of what ownership there is
when we were thinking of
thank you mr leila mr bryant
i'd like to join mickey leyland in
thanking all of you for being here all
of you have already made it in your
industry obviously
you're not here speaking only for
yourselves but for a lot of other people
i'd like to ask this question we've been
here for nearly four hours and it's been
difficult for me in the course of the
two panels to
develop
a clear idea of what specific action
that this committee
ought to take
if we're to address the problem that we
all agree exists and i think everybody
you're to some extent with this
committee we've been preaching to the
choir this morning because most of us
came here with
a similar view of the circumstance that
you have
most of the solutions that have been
mentioned this morning relate to
encouraging minority ownership
of
i guess
production studios
or of
of the broadcast outlets themselves and
i wonder
in view of the various levels at which
decisions that are discriminatory
are made
if
simply addressing ownership is enough
all of us up here i believe have
are co-sponsoring legislation presently
to try to encourage more minority
ownership
of those two
different entities but i wonder that's
all that i've heard discussed this
morning i wonder if that's enough
it would be very hard for us to own a
network
let's be realistic gentlemen
it's very difficult now when you look at
the us commission on civil rights
statistics of what ownership there is
when we were thinking of having cbs
getting into cable
and if we own cable cbs could produce so
much more
and own many more stations than we
that their product would go out across
the nation
while if one or two of us owned a cable
station
we may not have the money to put into
production we just don't
or couldn't
compete with the triopoli you were
speaking of
i don't see why at this point we should
talk about ownership only because there
are a plethora of jobs from the top on
down
in every studio in every network
in every independent station in every o
and o and affiliate
where we should be employed in the total
creative process
so ownership
is not the only answer it's only one
among many
well my question is and mr carter go
ahead and answer that my question though
is what else can we do you had one
creative solution uh
which related thank you
yeah sir i i believe that there's a
great deal that we can do that we have
not done and that we really have not
spoken about
i am very sensitive to uh
chairman wirth's call for quantification
i think that quantification is the
solution
now i did not use that word in my
remarks but i think that the essence of
it was that i do feel
that we can quantify
our
the solution to our grievances
i think
that we could work out with your help
with the help of legislation a system
whereby the television industry the
telecommunications industry
becomes as responsive to the minority
community as other industries are now i
know that by legislation i'm not too
familiar with it but i know that by
legislation uh there are guarantees in
many industries that that have been uh
delinquent in the area of affirmative
action
and i'm not speaking merely of jobs you
see i'm speaking of participation and
the kind of participation i'm talking
about
deals with that pervasive aspect of
telecommunications which has to do with
the images on the screen
and i'm saying to you
that if legislation if the congress
could
grab the networks and the producers by
the scruff of the neck and make them sit
down
knee-to-knee with us and discuss how we
can help them become more responsive to
the world's needs
in a manner that they are not fulfilling
their responsibility
i think that
what could be gained thereby first of
all
if minority producers are by contract
doing a getting a piece of the action if
you want to put it so crudely
then obviously
more minority people are going to be
working
more minority people are going to be
working on all levels
more minority programming is going to be
made whether it gets on the network or
on syndication or on cable or on home
video cassette or or theatrical rerun or
foreign
or foreign sales
product will be will exist that does not
exist today in addition to which all of
those minority producers will be gaining
the kind of experience that can help
them to compete with the air and
spellings of the world i i had a network
executive tell me
that
the main reason they don't deal with
minority producers is that minority
producers don't have a track record
well obviously the reason minority
producers don't have a track record is
that aaron spelling in lorimar and
universal studios they're at the finish
line and we we can't get out of the
starting gate
so
they deal with with something that they
have caused as if that's that's a that's
a justification so what i'm saying is we
if we can quantify and we can
for example if i may give you an example
the
prime time syndication and interest
issue is i understand an eight hundred
dollar a i'm sorry 800 million dollar
i'm not used to using those figures 800
million dollar annual issue
if twenty percent of that small pie
relative small relative to the to the
billions of revenue dollars of revenue
that come into the industry if twenty
percent of that small pie 160 million
dollars
were allocated by the industry to
minority production and when i say
minority i obviously mean native
american and latino and black and asian
and probably others that might apply
if that were allocated to us just think
of how much product could be made from
that and maybe we'd convince the
networks i'm optimistic that some of the
product that we put together might be
fine for eight o'clock on monday nights
or might be fine to release as a
theatrical film cbs does a lot of
backing of theatrical films incidentally
or might be fine to to to be syndicated
and shown on their own and operated
stations it would give us an opportunity
to
gain some of the experience and also
some of the the the capital that we
require to be able to stand on our own
feet and it would help to satisfy some
of our needs as a community to see our
images on television however it might
happen i see that it would be a shot in
the arm personally and i think that
quantification is a is a word that that
that capsulizes it that is its
quintessential definition
congressman i would like to second mr
carter's
ideas
i feel that
in order to solve the problems that
we're faced with
that we must have
the access to production dollars to
produce programs to create viable
companies
many times the networks have raised the
bugaboo of violation of their first
amendment right of freedom of speech
when people start dictating to them what
kind of programming they should put on
television
they scream that it's a violation of
their rights for somebody to tell them
that they should reflect the reality of
america
well i don't believe that there's
anything involved
with dollars with money that involves
the first amendment
dollars can be allocated
and then the programming that is
produced of that is free of that
particular complaint
that they keep talking about
certainly the vertical integration of
the employment practices of the networks
and studios in independent companies
must be addressed
we have no decision makers at the top
levels
and we must become a part
of the institutions that create this
programming
apart and separate an addition to having
production companies
it's not everybody wishes to take those
sort of risks because you one must be
willing to take risks when one goes into
private business i personally do hold
the aspiration of owning a network
and would not give that up
which one
anyone i'll take any of them
and um now owned three cable companies
and uh one could have said that that was
a pipe dream for someone coming from
east l.a
whose father was a cook
but nevertheless i have achieved that
dream and i feel that i have the
capacity to take more business risks
and risk the home
and security of my children
my wife's not too happy about but i'll
continue to do it
but i must emphasize that vertical
integration and employment is a
fundamental importance
and legislation
can ensure that that occurs and that
there is also the capital available
for production
by minority owned and controlled firms
not by sham
companies that are set up to circumvent
legislation that might require it
i think that that
would be a concrete step forward that
this committee could pursue
mr bryant's time has expired are there
other comments on his question as to
what should we be doing as a
subcommittee well if i may mr chairman
in
i certainly agree with my distinguished
colleagues
mr esparza and mr carter
but i would just like to mention that
if we
if we indeed
do not maintain the comparative renewal
uh i was listening to earlier the panel
as it relates to
minority programming
ownership employment
needless to say
if we
if we did not
maintain it there would be i think a
tremendous loss and so i wanted to to
simply add that to the record of what
what we need to think in terms of and
what we need to do in addition to what
my colleagues in addition to why we are
here to stress uh uh the uh the things
that we've already stressed i would like
to go back and and add for the record
that
to maintain comparative renewal is is
is of extreme importance for the high
quantification
standard
we have one witness has joined us who
had not been able to
get here earlier if you might want to
come to the witness table now mr bourne
okay well mr boyne if you have testimony
we'll be happy to
include that
in the record mr bourne is also a
producer from new york city mr swift
thank you mr chairman
first of all i might note this is the
has been the most literate testimony
that
i've heard since i've been in congress
and perhaps mr chairman we should try to
include artists more frequently so we
don't
totally forget the proper use of the
english language
around here we're subject to a lot of
attorneys
secondly
in my earlier questioning the question
about whether or not minorities were
adequately portrayed in soap operas came
up and mr hooks who was at that time not
at the
table
uh seemed to have something urgent to
say and i think we should fill in the
record at that point did you or
listen i think i had spun off of dr
mcdonald saying that they were there
were some accurate
representations as accurate as soap
operas were and you seem to disagree
with that and i thought we should get
that right we simply wanted to know you
go ahead terry we we simply wanted to uh
to to to uh stress that uh what you were
saying to the to the previous panel we
have we've dealt with the question uh
probably more often
than they
but
the julia
thing that you mentioned
i recall
also uh the uh the experience of the
oreo
uh repercussion
uh it it it at the time uh was i think
uh
valid uh based on on
uh congressman leland's response to the
time
uh and to the uh the motives of the
networks to to uh avoid uh elude uh the
realities of of black lifestyles
what uh
was happening in in in the black
community
what in some instances are still
happening because of uh of the lack of
concern for black uh
uh for meaningful uh
black portrayals on television uh but uh
i i simply wanted to nobody was
answering the question and i i simply
wanted to and then of course mr leland
referred to
to it
to the times but i think that
it i was one of the you probably heard
my cries about the oreo
at the time to me it was indeed not in
order
uh it uh
but in
in the same
in the same instance it was uh
acceptable to to to me as a
as a positive
step
but certainly
i would have produced
many more
images before the
the oreo image i just want to give you a
chance because you obviously felt
strongly about what i wish i could have
shouted it from back there then than it
probably would make it also it's it's
true too that we shouldn't expect
minorities to react to anything with
unanimity any more than we expect
anybody else to react to anything with
unanimity
um
let me move on to another point you
mentioned that there are any blacks in
capital
that's only one of an almost unlimited
number of inaccuracies
in capital which raises the question of
what what you people are pleading for
very articulately is some realistic
representation in a field that is often
unrealistic in every aspect i don't know
how much truth there is about texas and
dallas
or in a lot of other things
and it i'm not suggesting you were
therefore wrong for pleading for it but
i think it shows the dimension of the
problem you're facing
because much of what is on television
doesn't represent truth about anything
to anybody
is that not true which moves you one
further step away from getting a
realistic presentation may i respond
congressman
what you say is true of course uh
the networks and the producers will
hasten to say
that they're not putting on
documentaries that they're not
necessarily meaning to portray reality
but the strange part about it is
enormously successful that not yet yes
indeed
the problem that i see is that it always
works in our disfavor
because if they're not meaning to
portray reality
why can't they have a situation where
there are more minorities than there are
in real life why is it when we say we
talk to them about casting uh
a let's say an asian person in a
situation where in reality maybe maybe
there's no
asian
doctor in the city of uh peoria as a you
know
hypothetical example they'll say well
there are no asian doctors here so we
couldn't have an asian doctor
and yet they will do all kinds of other
things that are fantasy and fiction
they'll have nuns that fly you know
nobody questions that they'll have
genies coming out of bottles they'll
have dogs and horses that talk and cars
that talk
that kind of fantasy is okay but when it
comes to fantasizing what a
heterogeneous and diverse world this
could be that seems to be beyond their
capability of fantasy and that's the
part that makes me angry i don't care
whether they give us realistic
representation give us diverse
representation and i'd like to make a
comment if i may congressman about the
controversy over julia
i happened to be in the minority at the
time of the julia controversy because i
did not fi i did not find julia
offensive and i as you have aptly said
uh we cannot expect black people to be
in unanimity or on any issue any more
than anybody else
my feeling was that the the
sad part was that
the only thing we can talk about is
julia
if they had several shows on the air and
one happened to be about an upper middle
class nurse who dressed very better than
most of us etc etc and another one
happened to be about a a teacher who's
struggling to pay their her rent or
whatever you know what i'm saying is if
there were diversity we wouldn't be
dwelling even now 15 years later on the
issue of julia the pathetic part is that
we have very little between julia and
1983 to discuss
i guess it would follow that you
wouldn't be so upset at the portrayal of
mr t if he were in the context of a
broad range precisely precisely put
i was going to speak to to to that issue
what i think the issue is here is
balance and
if you the white viewer for instance
complained and did not like archie
bunker because he was a racist and and
you could turn
turn the channel and you could get
uh hill street blues saint elsewhere and
and you could get a good strong balance
regardless of whether you get a talking
horse or a talking car process you would
get an interesting diversity a balance
we uh if i'm if i have george jefferson
running around acting like a buffoon on
my television set and i did not want to
to for my kids to see that
i can't i don't i can't turn away and
get a balance i can't turn away and get
a black realistic dramatic scene with
some good strong role models we don't
have that luxury it's about balance and
diversity and i think that
uh
that is
that is one of the one of the one of the
main problems with network television
today
in the in the programming sense and and
the mr t's just don't make up for it
could could i ask a question to help me
understand
this balance how did you feel about the
program paris it didn't last long i
thought paris was a was it was a i
thought i loved james earl jones i
thought paris was an interesting show
but paris was not a by any means a black
show paris the only black person in
paris was james well there were three
black people james earl jones mike
warren leading character the leading
character the stories
the stories were the same boss
i mean it had it had those kinds of
qualities that that are useful are they
not in trying to to seek for a seek a a
more balanced image
well the the the stories don't i mean
the james the character of james l jones
the lead character the stories were i
mean it was the same as if it were
kojak with a with a black personal
police shoot them up exactly and and
white writers wrote the scripts blacks
didn't had no input there uh
the same was with the the lou gossett
series lazarus syndrome uh you cannot
just take a black actor and put him in
the lead role without having
and call it a black show or or even call
it a a a good strong black image if you
don't deal with what this person is
talking about what situation this person
is confronted with very helpful to me to
understand in greater detail what it is
you're saying two
more points one i think i hope to
reinforce something that miss heru
pointed out if i can use you uh mr
carter i uh
both of us have got a little gray in our
hair since you were on mccloud but uh
and i didn't recognize you i'm sorry to
say though i watched that program and
your performance
quite regularly i didn't watch
the battlestar galactica but
in terms of this tvq are you not in the
position now of having been in three
television series
multi-year series so you're around for
quite a while haven't been on the air in
four years and doesn't your tvq have a
half-life doesn't that begin to
disintegrate after some time thus making
it harder for you then to to get back in
don't you have that catch-22 kind of a
problem i i suppose i do i'm not sure
that i ever really had a tvq you see the
problem is that the industry pretends
that the tvq does not exist they have
stated so publicly and i guess you're
aware of that so i'm never in a position
to know
whether i have a tvq at all and if i do
what it is and how long it lasts what is
the shelf life i have i'm afraid i
couldn't answer that question
um i'd like to make a comment if i could
about a prior question that you raised
please
i'd like to take a different position
from my colleague mr hooks about the
ques about about paris
unfortunately there are many many
variables that determine the success of
failure of a television show
one of those variables has to do with
the quality of the writing
one of those value
variables has to do with the
the um
the time slot that it's put in what is
it put opposite
one of those variables has to do with
how much they promote that show
because they had the networks as you
know have taken often mediocre shows
and promoted the heck out of them and
they made them into successes
the problem is as i see it sir
that we
do not have the luxury of being able to
fail
if you look back over the last 10 or 15
years you can count
i guess by now hundreds
of shows that have been on television
for a very brief time and failed
nobody said that they failed because
they were white shows
but the minute of paris
fails they say well we gave it the
office we tried and it didn't work so
we're excused from doing it anymore
and that's the problem that we have
1941
heaven's gate the list is very long of
the colossal failures that have come out
of hollywood which proves to me that
hollywood does not have have the formula
for for success if they did they
wouldn't violate that formula everything
is trial and error and all we're asking
them to do is to include us in their
their experiments and to to to have the
courage of that experiment to do if
you're going to put on a show
advertise it let people know that it's
on the air and then if it fails fine
let's say that it failed maybe it failed
because of the time slot or maybe it
failed because we didn't have the right
director on the show or maybe it failed
because we didn't promote it enough or
because that particular person who
happened to be black who was headlining
the show was not appealing enough to an
audience but don't make that reflect on
all the minority people out there in the
world who are not necessarily
represented who should not be
represented by one effort on your part
and that's what we suffer from that's a
terrible important point because the
variables are infinite and probably no
one really knows why a show fails when
you really get down to it anyway one
last point
a professor that i used to have
named taylor created taylor's first law
which was do not ascribe to conspiracy
where stupidity will suffice for an
answer
i gather from things that were said by
this panel that stupidity or
insensitivity or apathy or even an
uncoordinated racism does not suffice
for an answer to you people in terms of
explaining why
you were in the position you're in today
is that correct
uh for the record four heads nodded yes
may i yes mr carter
at the risk of speaking too much i would
like to respond to that sir
roots
remains today the highest
rated television miniseries in the
history of television
those greedy people
who run the networks and i call them
greedy because well
they're out to make money and i and i
think that that seems to be their only
concern so perhaps it's
precipitous of me to use that severe
word
but
if they if their greed were if they were
greedy enough
they would say
by george we can make money by putting
on programs about black people
because they know it because roots and
other shows have proven it
and yet they don't
so we have to feel that it's no accident
because it is it should be quite clear
to them and i think it is quite clear to
them
that
a a program which is well produced and
well acted and well-written
is going to be appealing they know that
they know that
there have been movies that i that we
could that we could touch upon that have
been successful that have had sounder
that was on the air i think was it last
night
it was in rerun
on cable in los angeles we all remember
sounder it was a story about a black
family it had a tremendous success it
warmed the hearts of americans of all
colors now why is it that we find
ourselves in 1983 in this kind of a dead
end this narrow dead end where where our
perspectives are so narrow and our
memories are so short
it it seems to us
that it has to be conspiratorial because
if it's not why are they not responding
just just in a matter of dollars and
cents why are they not consistently
greedy
excuse me mr congressman certainly i'm
sorry mrs mr
uh i would uh at this point like to
officially uh
i we brock peter is our distinguished
colleague was supposed to be here today
and could not make it because he's on a
soap opera couldn't get away
uh
i would like to
officially offer his testimony
to be accepted into
the record without objection that and
other uh relevant testimony from your
group will be included in the record at
full at the appropriate point thank you
mr case right and i'd i'd also like to
just simply say that in another panel i
was happy that we were able to get the
diversity that we were able to get from
the minority community but
i was especially impressed with
dr fred mcdonald
and his statements on the on the
previous panel some i was happy that he
was able to be here today
simply
i thank all of you and i thank the
chairman
uh gentlemen and miss haru we thank you
very much for being with us again we
greatly appreciate your
input
we have as you can see a
a
through a problem that has parallel
tracks right we are concerned as mr
swift has pointed out mr bryant mr
leland and miss collins and others
with the impact that television has on
this country that's what we're really
talking about and how people get
socialized by it the
little kid in africa who ran up to
mickeyland and said jrjr i mean there's
a kind of behavior that is transmitted
that is learned
one of the things that strikes me is in
all of this discussion of education that
we've heard
in the last six months this has become a
major topic
there's almost no reference in anywhere
but the nsf study that was out last week
to the impact that television has on the
education of our young
we hear over and over and over again
that television you know really hasn't
had a negative impact it hasn't hurt
kids but we know what it can do
positively just that jr example
it was a perfect
vignette to give us an indication of how
extraordinarily important this medium is
as people in our society kids and others
mr swift talked about growing up in one
kind of uh
i'm not quite sure what the term was
your own
a white area i grew up in a white area
too you know i didn't know black kids or
jewish kids or whatever were
and we didn't have television to watch
when we were little kids we had amos and
andy and that was it yeah
that was radio that was it that was very
important now the impact and the power
of that is what really i think we're
concerned there's a public interest here
as i was pointing out earlier and
talking about the telephone issue
there's a public interest here as well
as the financial interest or the greed
interest that you're talking about mr
carter there is that public interest and
that's what we're trying to get at
power this media how do we define that
and
if we change the law how does it get
changed to the point that we can really
define what that public interest is
to attempt to quantify that in a much
more explicit specific sense difficult
job
you all have a concern related to
minority programming and minority
producers and their participation and so
on that fits into our broader concern as
well
and uh we share your concerns i can
assure you i think you've gotten a sense
of that from
members of the committee here um mr
bryant's question remains the one that
we have to cope with what do we do
and that's what we'll be working on we
look forward to working with you all and
thank you very much for being with us do
any of you have comments that you would
like to make for the good of the order
in closing
i have one brief thing
we
continue to hear about first amendment
rights
and i think some consideration must be
taken
that the first amendment rights
of people of color
are not
being given to us
by
the fact of our exclusion from the media
thank you
could i could i uh amplify that point
someone once said that unfortunately
the first amendment rights belong more
to the guy that owns the newspaper
or in your instance the guy that owns
the network that was aj liebling who
said that in his book the press i
remembered very well well the crux of
the crux of our message today especially
in mr casey's sense is that they have
the right to lie on us they have a right
to call us pimps and prostitutes and
whatever and all of the negative things
but they also have the the the freedom
of speech to say something nice about us
and they don't and we cannot we have a
redress and that is the unjust
uh part of it we we don't own the
networks we don't own the airwaves so we
can't come back as they say in the
neighborhood we can't come back at nbc
if they say mr t is it
then the world
embraces mr t and i it is unfair
uh to blacks and of course the other
other minorities that are portrayed
negatively unfair to them also and that
is where the first amendment uh kind of
doesn't stand with us plus i don't know
of any right that doesn't have a
commensurate responsibility and that's
the issue here what are their
responsibilities to go along with their
first amendment rights that would all
defend
thank you thank you gentlemen thank you
all for being with us and the
subcommittee will be adjourned
yeah
well that's because i moved
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]